Five four,
three,
two,
one.
Yes.
And we're live Brian Callahan.
We are live on the Internet in cashmere right now.
Everybody catch me.
How come you don't wear watches?
You were just saying I don't wear it.
I don't.
I was thinking kind of saying that Brennan,
you could rob my house and there's nothing you'd find a value like there's not a
fucking thing.
It's still your car.
Oh no
wonder why you make money then.
Yeah,
well a lot of money,
right?
I do believe like not work for years.
I,
yeah,
I have enough.
I make money but I never,
I was thinking about that too.
I can,
I genuinely,
I did some soul searching about this because I watched how motivated Chavez.
He's so buttoned down about his stuff.
He's just always coming up with ideas and I don't think I ever gave to Fox for
real about fame or money.
I still don't,
I have a very precarious relationship with that.
What I love is coming up with new ideas and writing new stand up and you know,
like now having done the album and now I've got to come up with a whole new bag
of tricks that that's a really fun time.
I'm probably more happy or never as happy as when I'm on the road at some cafe
somewhere coming up,
solving problems,
coming up with new ideas and surprising myself and everything else.
You know,
I like hanging with my boys and laughing and like having a nice house.
Do you get any pleasure out of having a nice house?
Yeah,
but I could live.
Uh,
I have lived in rudimentary places and I have,
I don't notice.
Yeah,
I noticed that when I,
when I first started making money,
you get,
everything gets normal.
Like this is your house.
Wake up.
It's normal.
You know what doesn't change wouldn't always makes you feel good as views.
I was about to say that I can't believe you just said that you is not
underrated.
No views or views are very underrated.
I said,
interesting.
You say that.
I just said that,
you know also that to me,
Ray Kurzweil,
really?
Yeah,
he always lives in a place with a view.
When I interviewed him,
he was on a very high floor in an apartment building in San Francisco.
That's where he lives.
And You out,
you look out from his apartment and you see the city and you see the bay and
it's beautiful.
Yeah,
it's expansive.
Yes.
He said views are very important to him.
They are.
But I have another weird thing that like if you put me in a French cafe,
there's that,
there's a,
I don't know if it's still around,
but there was a fuss.
I'm so French just,
he took a phone sale.
We should.
Uh,
so my accent,
Samsung launched the jazz for him.
I said,
I speak French fluently.
I'm Camo.
Do Jumbo.
How well do you speak it for the line?
No,
I mean I used to speak it.
I went to French schools in Lebanon.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
I mean I can give me,
give me six months and I'm going to hop right back.
And then I think so the dating pool and from Shelly she see,
um,
what will you,
uh,
saying you're about to see something about?
You were in a cafe in France,
there's a place called Chez Paul,
which is,
uh,
this restaurant where you're crammed in with a bunch of people and,
and the walls and the wood has been there.
You know,
you go to the comedy store,
like a comedy,
like a comedy club that's been around since the 70s,
eighties yourself and you think these,
the wood in this,
this is a weird thing,
but the wood in these walls has it have absorbed so much laughter and good
energy.
I was just saying that the other day about the ice house.
Ah,
it's,
it's very special.
If they ever dump,
demolish that,
God forbid I would buy that wood and put it up on my walls.
Oh,
so you did it to match stuff.
Yes.
Magical stuff.
I like things that last,
I like marble and,
and heavy would like old railroad tracks.
Reclaimed wood.
Yeah.
I like this table.
Good leather.
He was reclaimed wood.
Yeah.
A man with a mustache and one aid,
things like that.
It's handmade.
I do crafts like,
like,
like if I had,
if I wanted to,
I would maybe go and have my shoes made in London.
I'd have bespoke shoes be spoke.
Yes.
That when they use that high,
now I'd have bespoke shoes.
The problem with jewelry watches,
nice shoes and everything is I have to maintain them and I,
I,
I'd rather have.
Mm.
I also think we have to maintain watches.
Just put them on.
That's right.
But I have a weird,
I have another weird thing,
which I think if I have leather under my feet,
I don't feel as secure and I don't feel like I can run or fight.
Oh.
Like leather soles.
I need some,
I need some rubber bro.
I gotta.
Yeah,
you should have some tread.
Yeah.
They can put some leather tread below the rubber tread rather below the leather.
You don't want those scuffed up leather,
bottom shells.
Those bitches are useless.
Not Socks.
Right.
But it's good for pivoting.
If you want to pivot,
like you want to throw it wheel kick,
it's really good.
Yes.
It's true.
If you want to bear down,
if I want to,
let's call it squash the bug when I throw my right and squash the bug with my
and my back foot.
No,
because you want to push off.
You want to have some something to push off.
You don't need that much pivot.
You really need pivot with a kick.
A spinning kick.
Yes.
Yeah.
This,
this is the kind of bullshit you and I still talk about it.
52 it's so that ever going to end,
well,
the fucked up thing is that w you know,
I am always getting ready for home invasion or a situation smart.
It might be the problem.
Is it that they're just too many things to worry about?
I can also,
I also have to worry about fucking ticks and things that I can't see like flesh
eating bacteria and Murcia worry about more than anything.
Honestly.
ASTEROIDAL impacts you too.
Yup.
Oh really?
Yeah,
because they can come and then wipe out civilization almost instantaneously.
There was something that I just retweeted a yesterday,
the Graham Hancock put up,
they found a new impact at 12,500
years ago,
that,
that coincides at the end of the ice age.
This is one of the things that he and Randall Carlson had been saying ad nauseum
and now Brian or Robert Schoch rather,
who's a professor at Boston University.
Did you hear about the,
uh,
explosion on the media that exploded in December,
December?
Yeah.
This media that exploded in December had something like 50 times these men on
earth power.
It didn't,
the atmosphere,
oh,
10,
10 atomic bombs,
10 times the power of the atomic bomb that exploded.
And Hiroshima.
Wow.
Yeah.
And it exploded in our atmosphere.
But no,
there's,
um,
this impact that they think happened and well,
there's two concepts.
Uh,
Robert Schoch thinks that it might've coincided.
These impacts might've coincided with,
uh,
he believes there's a great deal of evidence for a mass coronal ejection that
there was some sort of a,
a solar flare,
massive solar storm that happened,
which can periodically happen every few thousand,
every few hundred years something can happen.
And,
uh,
when that does happen,
it just wipes out everything.
And he said that there was thunderstorms.
It's like there's,
they'd sit thunderstorms or lightening storms that were like,
like the hail that was coming out outside that we filmed today.
Yeah.
But that,
but like lightning,
but that back please.
Jesus.
So this is the impact created that they found in Greenland.
Um,
it's 30 miles,
31 kilometers across,
which is not 15 miles.
Yeah.
Somewhere around 15 miles in fucking sanely.
Huge.
But do you think,
um,
as you think about your impending doom,
which is going to happen,
right?
I just worry about the civilization.
We're so dependent upon electricity and any small catastrophe,
oh,
this is,
they have an,
an impact video of where it hit.
Wow.
So it's all,
all this,
this hit like where there's glaciers right now,
but there's this massive impact they got hit man.
The,
the people that lived 12,500 years ago got hit.
They get,
there's more than one credit or two.
By the way.
This is one of the many craters that they found during the time period of 12,500
BC or 12,500 years ago rather to 10,000 years ago.
In that time period,
that 2000 year time period,
they think there was multiple impacts on the earth.
Why?
I guess it just wasn't our time now.
Well,
we're lucky we've just been through a really lucky stage,
but what he's saying essentially is that this is what wiped out the Egyptian
civilization,
the first Egyptian civilization.
This is what wiped out the civilization that built a called Beckley tappy.
This is what wiped out the civilization that preceded Sumir and ancient Babylon
and Mesopotamia,
that all those were rebuild
of a,
I can't wait for him to come back on again.
He's coming back on again.
Graham Hancock is coming back on again.
I think April,
the slam debate.
That other guy that you had on the podcast,
it was great.
Yeah,
wolves,
Michael Shermer,
who was actually a friend of mine who I like,
but he's,
he's a skeptic and there's an issue with skeptics and the,
the issue is not that it's not good to be skeptical.
It's very good to be skeptical.
The problem is when you approach things as a skeptic,
you're not approaching them as a scientist.
And I'm not saying that Michael Does this,
but that I think he did in that debate.
I think it was a mistake.
People,
they approach these things looking to debunk them rather than objectively
assessing all the possible evidence.
Right.
And so because of that you miss out on big thing like this is evidence,
this is a not like big foot tracks or some shit like that.
This is fucking real evidence of a crater that they have dated back to 12,500
years ago.
Yeah.
But people have a hard time believing in doomsday scenarios and because it kind
of like,
you know when you talk about taking the entire chessboard and throw it in the
air and you have evidence for it,
look at global warming and stuff like that.
There is a,
I really believe that people have,
whether it's late and are not a religious notion that we are ultimately sacred
and that God would never do something that terrible to us on moss.
And I really,
I really believe that like humanity itself to go away.
No,
because that would make no sense where we're moving in a certain direction.
We're making progress.
There's,
there's this sort of neural net.
It's becoming easier to understand what it is to be each other.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
and,
and that's kind of what virtual reality and being able to download other
people's brains will eventually do.
That probably brings us into one,
I guess universal consciousness.
I mean,
you can go on and on.
So the idea that that would be all be obliterated before it happens.
Before the singularity,
for example,
what happens is too much to bear.
It would make no sense for us because we have this narrative that we all kind of
adhere to.
It's very easy to do that.
Well,
it's a little psychological sort of,
sort of,
I want to say,
I want to say a trick that we play on ourselves,
but it's really a defense mechanism.
It's a little trick that we try to pretend that we're important.
God dammit.
Just look up at the sky and although you can't see it,
there are stars that are being swallowed up by black holes.
Yeah.
Like if the universe doesn't give a fuck about something that's a million times
bigger than the earth,
why would you think it gives a fuck about you eating stars?
That's a terrible question.
Most people,
that's a terrible insulting question.
The problem,
you know,
that's kind of what,
um,
uh,
who has an Albert Kamoo,
the French existentialist and start and all those guys,
they were saying like,
come,
who said the,
the fundamental question is why wouldn't you,
why not just commit suicide?
Because everything is totally absurd and nothing means anything,
right?
It's like the rock of sis that you keep pushing up and it keeps rolling down.
And then he said,
but,
but the truth is most people don't want to kill themselves,
but they'll commit philosophical suicide.
Meaning instead of like really starting to ask these questions and really
getting into it and realizing that it's all hopeless in despair,
you know,
you,
you just,
you just glom on to a certain philosophy that gives you hope,
religion or whatever it might be,
which is what it is.
And maybe the way out of that is just to enjoy every day,
taste your food,
enjoy your friends and realize that it could end in any,
in any second.
You know,
one another thing that's fucked with me,
the concept of reincarnation,
not the concept of re incursion,
coronation look coming back as a butterfly or something like that.
But the concept of living your life over and over and over again until you get
it right.
Oh Jesus.
Now here's what fucks with me.
I am having a great time.
So why wouldn't I want to do this again?
I'm having a great time.
I have great friends like you and young Jamie over there and I have,
I love my family.
I love what I do for a living.
I love our circle of friends is amazing.
I mean,
we are for sure some of the luckiest men I've ever met in my life.
There's no doubt.
There's no doubt we have fun,
man.
Dude,
I was thinking about all the mistakes I've made,
but then I went,
wait a minute,
but I'm here.
52 I'm here.
I've made a fuck load of mistakes.
We all are.
We are,
but we're also risk takers.
I mean,
we're professional performers.
We want to a job that has zero job security.
Yeah,
fucking head first,
no safety net.
Dove right in.
You know,
we make mistakes when we make mistakes with our,
our job.
We make mistakes with our personal life and make a mistake with it.
There's just no [inaudible],
no way of knowing because,
because I don't have a dress rehearsal,
I'm a presented with these.
I'm presented with the scenario.
I have to make a choice in real time.
I'm going to make a mistake.
And,
and once I realized that and stop beating myself up about it and realize that
I've always done the best I can.
But here's where you,
here's what you can do.
Be brutally honest and assess yourself and see where you're falling short and
then just change your approach.
So that's kind of what I do.
When I saw acting,
when I saw what just being an actor was and I saw how precarious it was and I
saw where the business was moving with the like new media and stuff and I was
like this doesn't make I.
Then I watched you doing your podcast and you would say start up high.
So guess what?
I started a podcast,
didn't go well,
start another podcast,
didn't make money,
then started a third podcast with Brennan shop and Blah Blah Blah.
But you know it's same thing with stand up.
You just keep doing it.
You keep following the models that work cause I was doing it the wrong thing
over here.
And next thing you know,
you know you've got to grind underground.
That's where a lot of comics fuck up.
Like they do it like once a week and then they take a few weeks off and then you
come back and do it again.
And they're like,
how do you do it all the time?
I'm like,
cause I know how to grind.
I'm a grinder.
It's not just grind.
Like for me the idea is original self expression.
I'm interested in trying to take the way I think so a lot of things scare me and
they make me angry and I don't know how to know how to react,
but you know,
instead of fretting about it,
I create,
you know Michelangelo,
my favorite quote,
criticized by creating a great fucking Croak and he said that's beautiful.
Yeah,
he said that.
He said criticized by creating.
I always think about that because that's kind of when I look at my body of work
in the progression of my,
my specials for example,
like man class a little too,
you know,
just about being funny in a silly goose.
Then never grew up a little more personal but my dad,
but then this last one,
complicated apes.
Where's my camera out right now?
It's out right now.
Oh my God.
Is this the number one iTunes comedy albums,
rank things.
Apparently it's crushing and anywhere you could.
It's number one in the world where you can rent and buy.
I guess complicated apes is doing very well.
If you want to get it and laugh hard and learn,
feel like we should celebrate.
This is not one.
This is not about promoting my special.
We should feel you should promote it a little bit.
All right,
fine.
Get complicated.
[inaudible] let's just get that right now.
Right?
I guess it's out right now on iTunes or anywhere you are.
[inaudible] terrible TV.
You could just watch it on your TV,
Xbox or playstation.
You can listen to how you can get on Amazon.
I don't stop any platform.
All the platforms.
You know,
Amazon is really getting into the special games.
Yes,
they are doing Alonzo Boden special.
He's going to be coming on soon.
Love Alonzo.
They're doing a good man.
He's a very smart guy.
Check.
Good Dude.
Um,
they're doing Jim Gaffigan special.
He's fucking hilarious.
Um,
and um,
I think they're talking to a bunch of other people but doing specials as well.
They decided to,
I love that there are all these other people love it.
And we're in the renaissance where we're stamps can make real money.
It used to not be that way.
You had clubs,
now you got theaters now you got a whole network now,
the Internet and everything else.
And what's beautiful about,
um,
the road now is I don't have to do that local press.
Oh,
that's so good.
Come see me in Kansas City this Friday,
Saturday and Columbia doing the Improv.
Louis Kansas City.
I love Kansas City.
Kansas City's,
I like it a lot.
It's fucking,
Oh hell yeah.
I did an outdoor theater there the summer.
Yeah,
it was fucking great.
Me and seeing Tino really fucking amazing man.
Really an outdoor theater.
Really Fun.
That's pretty bad ass.
Yeah.
Kansas City's a shit.
It's one of those places that people forget.
St Louis.
That's also the sh the shit.
That's a fun place.
But to me it's terrible town.
Now here's how,
how dare you,
first of all,
barbecue St Louis,
I had a little problem with,
but Kansas City.
Fantastic.
What kind of problems you have?
I just thought it was very ugly city.
Maybe you're generalizing,
maybe.
Maybe you didn't go to the pretty spot which go over like Kugler.
He'd drive all over the whole fucking city.
I drove around.
How about Cleveland?
This is where we draw the line.
I like cleaning.
I fucking love clean.
Let me tell you why.
Like leaving.
It's a beautiful city.
I mean talk about architecture.
It's like Pittsburgh,
us and some great holidays.
He said like Pittsburgh.
Yes,
that's true.
That's totally true.
It's wet.
It's where the oil.
But then at some of the,
the iron,
I mean it was,
I think Clinton was where some of the richest people in the world where at one
point last time I was in Pittsburgh.
Well,
the first time rather,
I said,
well,
not even the first time.
One at a time.
So I was in Pittsburgh.
I was there for a furry convention.
Oh,
I was there for the UFC and the UFC was in Pittsburgh at the same time.
A furry convention was on it.
That's when I found out about furries.
I had a nice long conversation with the dudes who work behind the desk at the
hotel.
They were telling me the firies were asking for their food in bowls.
They can eat off the ground.
Yeah.
They were all furries except us.
Like the fuck is going on.
Went with me.
I forget who opened for me.
It might've been Dunkin,
but um,
the,
they were asking for a litter box so they could shit and piss in a box.
I want to do that now.
You don't just for a laugh.
How are you gonna Wipe?
Where are you going to finish fetish?
Well,
it's like grown men who want to be a,
they want to wear diapers and have somebody spanked them and change them.
And well,
here's what's interesting and there's a lot of people that think that,
look,
I am a hundred percent in support of people being trans.
Don't get me wrong.
If you want,
I'm in sport.
I'm supporting you being whenever you want to be a person who believes in
freewill or,
or your,
your ability to freely express yourself,
I should say.
But if you work for a corporation,
you work for a Tech Corporation,
especially a particularly Progressive Tech Corporation.
You run into some real problems.
And I was talking to a guy who was telling me the,
you don't know the half of it,
that we're dealing with a guy who,
uh,
he identifies as an animal and that he,
he,
he believes that he's kin,
like he's a fox kin or a dog can or something like that,
and he wants a litter box in his office.
This guy wants to be able to shadow in his fucking office into a,
a box of,
now I,
I appreciate that.
Now I want to say this about him,
and I'm not a psychiatrist and I have no right to really diagnose,
but he's fucking crazy.
He is crazy.
Right?
But here's the thing,
like you're letting people be crazy correct when you're letting a six foot four
man compete in women's weightlifting because he's decided that he's a woman now
and,
and now he's winning and he's wearing makeup and he looks like a gorilla and
he's on stage lifting his arms up.
Yay.
Diversity.
You're,
you're stealing from women's stealing,
you're stealing victory,
cheating,
you're cheating.
You're fucking 100% cheating.
Anybody says or not you're an asshole,
you're an asshole.
But you know,
this is about humanness.
And when,
when,
when someone's feelings,
how they identify in that moment,
which of course is so transitory,
right?
I mean I'm,
I the hope my fucking,
not to bring it back,
but the whole idea of complicated apes is this,
your,
your new specialties and it's available basically everybody,
right?
Amazon,
you could get it on iTunes.
You have it.
It does.
Oh my God.
And wherever the fuck under here,
if I look
in your sock drawer,
there's my specialty is in your sock drawer.
But,
but,
but I,
but I do think that,
you know,
we are complicated like were were bipolar apes,
sinners and saints and everything in between.
None of it.
Your feelings,
how you feel.
Sometimes I feel like an asshole.
And other times I feel like a saint and everything in between you,
you know,
it's very difficult to say,
well,
this is your a noun,
which means you're,
this is opposed to sort of a verb,
which is I'm always changing and that that to me is the problem with when you
identify,
when you,
when you emotionally identify with something,
well for now you do for now that that's what's important to you.
But I can't,
I can't tailor my life and my entire corporation,
this is what the part of the problem is and this is what you just hit on.
Part of the problem is these people want to be special for no reason at all.
Correct.
And so to be special for no reason at all,
one of the best ways is to do a Bruce Jenner.
Did you become Caitlyn Jenner?
And then he special.
That guy was a fucking loser even though he was a gigantic superstar in the
Olympics 40 years ago.
But from then on they shat on that guy every fucking show.
That's right.
They shit on him.
He was the buffoon of that show.
And then all of a sudden he becomes a woman ever.
It's like,
you're amazing.
And we'll meet women the year after I a woman for six months.
All the women that do things I cribbed Christina Dowd know came up with Chris
because CRISPR cas nine and all those one.
Oh,
is this the guy?
Okay,
this is hilarious.
This is a dude who's a comic,
is a comic.
He's a rapper and he's fucking jacked.
So he decided to identify as a woman wanted me to.
So,
and if he destroys the British women's deadlift record without even trying.
Wow.
Psi identified as a woman whilst lifting weights don't be a bigot.
I love his mom and he's so jacked.
Imagine that.
So two biological men don't have any physical strength advantage over women in
2019 okay.
Anybody says that is a fool.
That's foolish.
There's a reason why.
Yeah,
good for him.
What's his name?
Zuby.
Zuby is his stage name.
Shout out to Zubin Oxford graduate.
It doesn't that mean you're a Rhode Scholar?
Zubie congratulations to you,
sir.
I'm following you right now.
I'm going to go right to my God damn.
Twitter for free is a free,
God bless you.
Look,
it's like this is silliness for six these and here's the problem with a lot of
these progressive's is that they're really nice people.
That's what it is to be.
Follows me and now I follow him.
Shout out to Zubin.
They're nice people as long as you agree with them.
Yes,
exactly.
Don't they tried to Ddi platform you?
I got listed.
Tim Pool sent me this thing.
Ready next to Richard Spencer as being a far right influenced me.
Far right was it?
They called me far right.
That's amazing.
I'm left.
They're liars.
I am fucking left.
Did that ball.
You know the socialist?
Yeah.
I consider universal basic income.
Have really good idea.
I want free college education
could easy.
I would like to spend more in taxes.
If they could fix inner city communities and take these poor neighborhoods and
we spent a lot of them spend more you fucking Republican.
The more money you spend,
it doesn't.
The problem is money doesn't solve problems.
That's the price and you son of a bad deal.
It coming out of your pores,
you socialists,
why don't you leave my country?
It's 6% African.
So watch your fucking mouth,
dude.
No one cares is so compassionate.
Compassion is everything.
But I think these people were too compassionate.
This is what the problem is.
They're like,
oh,
you identify as a Wood Elf.
Oh cool.
You're an Elf.
I don't want to,
I didn't,
you know,
like whatever your feelings,
and here's the thing.
They're terrified of someone coming after them.
So they tried to embrace the more preposterous,
the better.
Yeah.
Like they're,
they're having a real hard time now with this woman,
the congressman,
you know who said a bunch of antisemetic Shia,
they stop,
right?
Antis really shit.
Is it antisemetic has she said anything bad about Jews and general anti Israeli
stuff,
which,
which I think you can make a distinction,
I think,
be able to,
I think you should be able to make an intelligent argument that there is a
difference between being not anti Israeli,
but having problems with their policies and Jews because there are a lot of Jews
that are critical of Israel as well.
100%.
Yeah.
So it's,
you know,
but sometimes to silence you and stop the argument.
I don't,
I'm not familiar with what she said exactly,
but I'm not either.
Yeah.
Um,
but,
but yeah,
but go on.
What were you saying about,
about uh,
the problem,
they don't know what to do with her.
They're stuck in this weird spot because they don't like,
here's a perfect example.
Where was it?
Um,
was there,
so it was somewhere in Europe where these,
this Muslim group was shouting down this LBGT demonstration and the like,
everybody's like,
oh,
well,
Jesus,
what do we do here?
We have to protected classes going to war with each other.
And one of them is shouting down.
The other one's saying that homosexuality is forbidden by God,
but then we're supposed to be protective of LBGT.
People were supposed to be open minded and progressive and allowing them.
But,
but then you have these people who were saying that it's their religion,
that they think that this is,
this is wrong.
And this is also a protected class.
You don't want to be Islamophobic.
So what does everyone do it where everyone stands back.
And this is one of the weird moments where people are standing back while Lbgt
people were getting absolutely crucified in the streets,
yelled at with bullhorns,
told her being they're sinners in blast females,
that that actually is part of free speech,
right?
So,
so it's part of organized and expressed yourself.
Organize in petition your government that's constitutional.
As long as you don't incite someone to violence,
as long as you don't say,
Hey,
you guys go kill those gay people over there.
Well I'm not talking about constitutionally,
constitutionally.
I agree it is free speech.
But what
I'm saying is that there's no outrage.
There's no commensurate outrage.
Like there would be if say like white nationalists were screaming at these
people.
So,
so here's my issue with the far left or the left,
or even,
I forget the right for a second.
I have my own issues with that.
But my,
what the progressive argument,
I always noticed that the narrative is very binary.
The narrative is always a,
so for example,
uh,
racism as the argument,
right?
So we need to get rid of racism.
I happen to think we could be as identical as penguins and we'd still find
reasons to break into US versus them.
Well,
we'd have an ideological,
but of course we did look,
look at the Middle East.
If racism is the,
was the the ultimate problem,
then the Middle East would be fairly,
would be a Sunni and Shia,
the Ebo and Yoruba.
I mean I can keep going with the,
there'd be all kinds of,
so people are looking at the Dinka and the new of the sedan sworn enemies,
they look exactly the same.
So human beings don't need to have different colored skin.
I couldn't agree more.
Yeah.
So,
so,
so we are tribal and it's fun to break into these us versus them.
I think the biggest problem is,
is kind of deciding that first of all,
the Internet has made it very possible for you to purify your echo chamber.
Yeah.
That's a big problem.
And,
and then you surround yourself with people who think and,
and see the world exactly like yourself.
And I think we get smarter when we listened to the other side of me.
If you don't agree with them because your ideas aren't working and their ideas
are working,
but put your ideas together and maybe somebody gets pregnant with a new idea,
you know the,
the ideas that there's some way that you could stop all division between human
beings.
As long as people are allowed to express themselves and they live unique and
individual lives,
that's never gonna happen.
You're gonna have people that come from different parts of the world where
different things are more important.
You're going to have people that come from different economic situations.
It's going to be different.
I mean,
when,
when I say that I'm almost a socialist,
what I mean is like,
look,
there's certain things that we just accept that we need.
Like here's one.
You need a well funded fire department,
right?
Who's,
who's money?
Everybody would pull in all our money into that grind.
Right?
We agree with that.
We agree there's well funded public education.
You have to have that right.
While we barely do that right now,
but we do have that teachers are getting fucked left and right.
They're getting minimal pay.
Children are going to school in hazardous conditions but it's at least there's
some money being pumped.
Police officers,
we agree so street fixing the streets.
We agree.
We agree on a lot of things,
but then it gets to certain things.
We go,
okay,
well that's where we draw the line.
Well why do we draw the line there?
Why do we draw the line when it comes to community up peoples like fixing,
fixing communities.
Why do we mean infrastructure?
Like chill.
Why do,
why?
Why don't we have like why don't we,
if we really a team or if the United States really team,
why don't we look at it as a team in terms of equal allocation of resources to
solve conflicts and problems including crime.
We don't.
We do a lot of times the problem is isolating the source of the problem,
right?
So people disagree on what the actual problem is.
I can give you examples.
I mean when,
when we talk about illegal immigration and what to actually do about it,
people are all over the board with it and they'll challenge your solution in
court and there's all kinds of steel and they switched probably is a good thing.
So things don't get too,
they don't swing too far.
And I think interaction,
a universal basic income,
universal healthcare con control,
these are actually fairly complicated issues.
You know,
I don't want spree shooters,
you know,
but when you get down to it and,
and you hear people that are really educated on the subject of guns,
they can get you twisted up in an argument.
If you start talking about gun control because you realize this is a complicated
issue and maybe it's a mental health issue,
maybe it's a thousand issue,
there's a lot of issues with it.
But the ability that someone has to do,
what is it wizard only one guy,
more than one person got arrested in New Zealand,
correct?
No,
I think it was just one guy.
They got arrested but only one shooter as far as I know.
So the other ones were planning it is out there,
maybe.
Yeah,
no,
I think he was saying.
Yeah,
but,
but my,
my thing is that point is that you have to be ill.
There's no other way.
You do have to be mentally ill nor to do that.
Now I want you to think about the fact there's more guns in there are people.
So in this country alone,
there's 300 plus million people.
There's more than 300 million guns,
relatively speaking.
The number of mass shootings is incredibly small in comparison to the amount of
guns and the amount of sick people and how many people are sick who don't become
mass shooters.
Right?
It's a big number.
Yes,
it's very true.
Those are things.
And a lot of the gun violence,
uh,
that the left talks about,
a lot of those are suicides.
So a lot of it.
Yeah,
a lot of that of suicides.
A lot of it is cops shooting bad guys,
a lot of his people defending themselves.
And then after that you have gang violence.
But so,
so let's say the problem is that when people argue they make these things very
simplistic and they're not,
you know,
even the,
even identity politics.
I mean,
you know,
straight white males are essentially the enemy.
So the idea would be if we take straight white males out of the equation,
because this is all power,
right?
It's all talking to Amy Schumer links now,
but I know I'm not.
But this tyrannical hierarchy and stuff as if,
if you took white males and took all of them out of the equation as if there
wouldn't be a new hierarchy,
that's fucking new code.
You know,
it's just the way shit happens.
People,
when you try to make things really equal in a communist society,
the people closest to the government making decisions,
they become the new elite.
So you're not gonna fucking know.
Avoid that shit.
You know?
And also there's no equality of effort.
The problem with the quality of income and equality,
people want success too.
They think that if you're more successful that it's because of some sort of a
cheat.
You've,
you've rigged the system or cheated somehow or another.
But that's not true.
Some people work harder.
They just,
they just do.
Of course,
some people become obsessed with success and some people,
my uncle,
my uncle Vinny doesn't give a fuck.
You know what my uncle Vinny does,
he makes art really sells it.
Yeah.
He's always been that way.
Used to be a photographer and now he uh,
he makes a,
he sent me some driftwood that he painted.
He painted signs from my daughters made out of driftwood.
He's just really,
he's so eccentric,
but he's never given a fuck about it.
Drove his ex wife Craig just makes beautiful things for,
he's an artist.
He's like a legitimate artists that way.
Jimmy Breck is truly not ambitious.
He is,
he is only interested in feeding his brain.
He loved,
like,
he listens to us.
Stephen West podcasts philosophize this,
which is my love that,
that's my new talking to that guy back and forth.
I'm going to get him on.
Yeah,
I got to get him on.
I love it.
He's 29 and he's got such a command and philosophy,
but he makes it so accessible.
Like Jimmy will start his day with philosophize this,
just listen,
can I get a nugget?
And then he goes and works out and plays tennis and just,
he's a national treasure because he only lives to educate himself and make the
world a better place.
He just makes people feel good about themselves and he's trying to enjoy life.
But do you think you'd want to do it over and over and over again?
The exact same life?
I do.
He's,
he's the happiest.
He's the closest thing to a monk.
I was just with him.
I,
I flew him down to Florida because I just had them on the podcast.
Folks who want to watch a disaster.
We got him way too high.
I got him like three or four hits deep and he doesn't smoke weed and he hadn't
eaten.
He hadn't eaten and he was thirsty.
I don't think the eating helps when you're smoking it.
I might be wrong,
does it,
but he was already low blood sugar.
Any haven't slept.
We barbecued that dude.
We threw him in a Traeger grill,
set it,
set it to 25 for six hours.
He was forgetting stories in the middle of the first sentence.
Amazing isn't bad.
We fucked him up,
which is too bad because he tells some great stories.
Now the world will forever know him as the guy who couldn't keep it together.
I remember when he had tuberculosis,
I called him Jimmy Tuberculosis.
Tuberculosis.
Sure did they think he got it from his grandfather when he was three years old
and it laid dormant and they couldn't find it because it wasn't on the outside
of his long.
Holy Shit.
I'm with him in the hospital.
I've never seen anything like this.
And he had,
they thought he had two things.
One,
the disease that killed Bernie Mac or two long sees killed bringing man.
He had a disease that firemen get from nine 11.
Uh,
we are lungs basically turned to sand.
I mean,
you know,
it's awful.
So Bernie Mac died of that.
So they said you have a,
either a fatal disease,
which is that lung disease or you have lung cancer.
Okay.
Now this was what he was looking at.
And I remember he was just talking to me like this dude it doot,
doot,
doot and joking around.
I Ha oh dude.
Yeah.
And I went,
Bubba,
I go,
you are,
you've been given like they are looking at you either being,
you know,
you're dead or dead.
I don't understand how you're not even missing a beat.
And he goes,
dude,
come on.
I've made peace with my death a long time ago.
I live every day as it comes.
Wow.
And He,
and that,
he was getting ready for them to come out and tell him what it was.
And the doctors,
you know,
you can't help but to love him.
So he was there for three weeks and the doctor finally found that he had
tuberculosis.
Now at this point,
all the doctors fell in love with them.
All of them.
They'd come in and listen to his stories.
So the doctor came running in and goes,
we found out what you have,
you have tuberculosis.
And to me it was like,
oh great.
And he goes,
no,
we can cure that.
This is fucking great.
We can care of that.
So he went on nine months of antibiotics,
nine and he went colorblind from the anabolic.
Yeah.
That's what happened to him.
He is now called color blind color.
Whoa.
That's the antibiotics did.
But Hey,
he's 100% but I remember,
I've never seen anybody faces his own death and be that just monk like about it.
He's done it.
Yeah.
Now when he was on the antibiotics,
the given probiotics as well.
I,
he does probiotics.
He brought his body right back.
I mean,
he is just a beast.
He's never stopped working out.
He's never stopped eating really well too.
They know what caused his anti biotic reaction that made him colorblind and
apparently is a side effect when you take nine months of a very strong cocktail
of antibiotics,
you know,
and that curate it though.
Nine months.
Yeah.
Thank God.
No Way.
It cures it on its own.
Well,
it back in the day you had consumption and almost you died eventually.
But some people would go up into the mountains and it would,
it would,
uh,
tuberculosis can go into remission and not come out again.
When you go to the mountain,
the idea was we'll go to the mountains and breathe fresh air and sometimes you
could go into remission with anthem,
with tuberculosis.
But Tuberculosis was almost always a death sentence in long day's journey into
night,
the great play and Nobel Prize winner,
Eugene O'Neill,
his brother had it and uh,
he knew his brother was going to die and uh,
he just watched his brother deteriorate.
It was like,
it was like having aids or something.
You would cough,
you'd spit up blood.
And I think she'll pat the great piano player died of it.
This is why when people talk about,
you know,
when they're there anti-vaccine or they're anti,
uh,
antibiotics or western medicine,
just read,
I forget every other science.
Don't,
don't worry about big Pharma.
Just pick up a history book or a piece of literature,
anything that's written before in 1950,
which most people don't,
1960 any classic book.
And the,
one of the central themes is,
is the fact that people,
especially children,
died.
Lincoln lost what?
Three of his children?
Three to fever,
quote unquote,
usually probably diptheria or something that came rolling through.
Smallpox was a fucking,
it was the biggest killer for Fr.
The Spanish flu of 1918 people alive.
20 million.
20 million people.
Unes of people.
Yeah,
so if you just don't forget,
I mean just pick up a history book or pick up a piece of literature.
It was unavoidable.
It's very [inaudible].
The Spanish flu apparently was a really weird one because it actively attack
people with really good immune.
Oh,
young people.
Young people got them better than it killed older people
for some strangers.
Yeah,
and that was a,
that was a fact of life.
You usually buried your children throughout history.
You had to bury your children.
That's a,
that's a unequivocal fact.
We don't live in that world anymore.
We don't worry about those.
Those diseases like tetanus and diptheria and things that would roll through and
just kill.
People are getting it now.
People are getting tetanus again.
Some kid got tetanus and I saw people arguing that one of the dumbest fucking
things I ever saw in my life,
someone was saying there's a simple cure to tetanus,
just expose it to open air or
is that a scientist?
Was that a guy who has his degree?
Why?
Wow,
this guy's never have a degree,
is that chem trail believer,
but why?
Why is it that all of these guys make the noise don't have degrees because they
want to believe that there's some sort of a,
some sort of an organized clan of people that train to keep your health down or
support big Pharma or there they're the real facts of diseases like smallpox and
like polio,
like all these horrific diseases that people in our grandparents' generation had
to deal with is that they were cured by Madison.
Yeah.
Yup.
It is modern Pharma.
Greedy.
Fuck.
Couldn't look no further than the oxycontin crisis.
The opiate crisis we were facing this,
this country.
Yeah.
Big Pharma left unchecked is like anything else where it's a corporation that
wants to have universal growth,
right.
They wouldn't have constant never ending growth and they want to keep making
money in the way to do that as a prescribed more people poison.
Ben Goldacre.
You ever had those podcasts?
He wrote a book called Bad Pharma,
but he's a doctor who takes a very,
he said they there is evil,
but you have to know what kind of evil.
Don't just throw the whole exact,
if you have Murcia you need big Pharma.
Fuck yeah.
You know.
Do you have staff?
Just talk to anybody who's ever wrestled there anything to Kim Haines son had
staff and he called me up.
He's like a how bad his staff,
I'm like Jesus Christ because he told me son got it at the gym.
I'm like,
get him to the fucking doctor immediately.
Now my wife's friend went into a coma.
She,
she was,
she started having seizures cause of an unchecked staph infection.
She got at the gym,
she started having seizures.
I'm at Sushi with Frank Grillo,
our buddy and he,
he boxes every day and I see his arm and he's kind of a long sleeve shirt and
his arms bleeding and I go,
what's going on with your arm?
And he goes,
I got cut.
I was at the gym and he's always on that dirty,
you know,
Matt or just do whatever.
In a literally seven hours his,
he had a sack hanging off his elbow.
Doctor Goes,
you got to get,
he almost lost his arm.
He had to get shots and antibiotics for a whole week.
I mean,
that shit moves quick,
moves very,
you would lose your arm,
your die.
I told you,
I'd tell you the arch of your story mean Aria playing pool and he's limping.
I'm like,
what's going on with your leg?
And he goes,
ah,
I think I've got a spider bite or let me see your leg.
He pulls his leg.
I go,
dude,
listen to me.
You're going to the doctor right now on screw my cue.
He's like,
are you serious?
I go,
we're,
we're quitting right now and I'm taking you to the fucking hospital.
I go,
you gotta go to the hospital now?
He goes,
now I go,
do you have a staph infection?
And it's bad.
And you could tell,
fuck yeah.
What?
It looked like a zit like a giant Zit on his knee.
I go,
that's our spider bite bro.
And he has been,
he was doing Jujitsu because of me.
I bought him a year.
I bought him a year membership for Jujitsu for a Hanukkah.
But uh,
yeah man,
it was fucking nasty.
And he would've just walked around with it and then it would have gotten really
bad and he probably would've got systemic and died.
Yeah.
My Bud happens to people.
My Buddy Ryan,
who was a health Gracie black belt,
they had to cut out,
they had to cut up an inch off of his shinbone because the screws.
So every time he'd be on antibiotics,
a year and a half in and out of the hospital,
it took them two years to recover with probiotics,
year and a half because the screws,
every time they put the screws back in,
they grooves,
the screws had the virus,
what's bacteria?
So he had to have,
when they took out the,
they took out the bone and they had to put a plate there.
They would use screws.
So for whatever reason,
the screws that were in the metal with,
somehow they were infected.
They kept infecting the bone.
Oh.
And they had to grow.
They had some aloe graft bone back on.
It was a fucking crazy.
Right.
It's no joke,
man.
Happy.
What's the,
something like that happens though?
How happy are you when you're healed?
Yeah.
I had a cold recently.
Just a little cold.
Not that bad,
but I was running ragged too many trips and too busy and getting up early and
going to bed late and I was just really tired and sick.
And then I couldn't work out for like four or five days.
And I remember thinking to myself,
you got to remember this.
You got to remember this shitty feeling when you can't even exercise.
And I'm Hawkin up Green Shit and spitting in the sink just to look at it.
I know.
Do you do that?
You blow your nose in the same course?
I do.
I do that.
I go,
yeah,
I want to see it.
See what it looks like.
Just,
yeah,
just big fucking smurfs.
Shit.
Big Green Gob.
Ewells all over the fucking sink.
But um,
I just remember thinking like,
you gotta be smarter,
stupid.
Just be smarter by having most of the time I am most of the time,
man.
But sometimes I just go,
I've got to hit that gas.
I got nothing in the tank,
but I got to fucking keep that accelerator pressed.
That's why I don't fuck around with my sleep anymore.
I read that book.
Why we sleep Matthew Walker,
he's amazing.
I,
I just,
I don't fuck around with my sleep and him should not,
you should not sleep is critical.
Yeah.
It's um,
you know what?
It is amazing for sleep,
man.
You know we should get in your place.
Get yourself a sauna.
Really,
really?
Oh yeah.
You do 20 close towns.
Some of that's for fucking clowns.
You wear a rubber nose when you do it.
Yeah.
Hey Man,
I did cold showers after yoga.
He wear our rubber nose,
man.
Joe's being mean to me.
Colombian clowns.
You'll fucking Cologne.
Welcome clown.
Tried to Quaive shock proteins.
I've got to get really cool.
You should have an ice bath.
You want to do that?
I'll do an ice bath.
I've done you done?
Crile?
Yeah.
Have you done the real one when you hit your head?
Goes in?
No,
he didn't.
The one where the neck below ana has the bullshit one.
Really?
Yeah.
The real ones only made by cryo healthcare.
They have one in New York or one center in New York.
They have one in La.
They have one here.
They want to woodland hills like 10 minutes away.
His path for 20 minutes and talk to me.
Um,
okay.
You go numb.
It sucks,
I'm sure.
But so does 250 degrees below zero.
Have you not done an ice pick?
Three minutes.
Yeah.
Come on Bro.
It sucks.
All right bro.
I get it.
You were a fucking Jew where I sat down nose.
I just double burned in a song.
I was singing.
Same.
Awesome.
Um,
yeah,
it's not good.
Um,
there's probably some real benefits to ice baths that benefit of,
um,
cryo over ice baths that you could work out right afterwards.
I spouse,
they recommend you not work out there.
Like you just chill out for awhile,
but it's great after working out.
But for muscle strength and development,
it's actually not good to do it right after training.
You actually should wait quite a while,
like maybe an hour or two.
So when you,
you've been,
you've had countless conversations with cutting edge scientists and exercise
people,
the five things that you do every day,
like that debt without fail,
what are they in terms of for your health?
First of all,
I supplement I think you believe in south,
I believe absolutely.
Wholeheartedly.
And supplements,
which though,
what kind of Tom?
I take athletic Greens.
It's a,
it's a sponsor.
Um,
they have,
it's a great whole food supplement.
I'm doing an ad form right now,
one,
one serving as 12 one scoop has 12 servings of fruits and vegetables in terms of
the amount of antioxidants.
And yet it's very healthy.
It's good just for like a backup plan,
right?
Like,
take these little packs with being on the road.
Um,
I take a lot of the Onnit Shit I take,
uh,
obviously I shouldn't be saying that shit.
Shroom tech,
you know,
w we have some awesome whole food supplements.
There's a bunch of great stuff.
Um,
I take a lot of vitamins.
I take vitamin D,
I take vitamin B,
I take a lot of fish oil,
a lot of essential fatty acids.
I believe in all those things.
I cut way back on my sugar.
I mean,
way back to where maybe once a week I'll have dessert.
Maybe let's do that too.
Yeah.
I don't fuck around man.
Um,
I just intermittent fast.
Yes.
16 hours a day.
Yeah,
I do that.
That makes me feel that,
you know,
my psoriasis is 100% gone.
That's awesome.
Part of it's also,
and I,
and I gotta give a shout out to Dan Garner.
Dan Garner 88 at Gmail.
If you need his email.
He's a fuck.
So he's the guy who was a terrible idea.
No,
no,
it's fine.
It's fine.
I want to,
I want to promote him because he's a fucking,
people are going to email be pictures of dicks.
Good.
But a lot of people have psoriasis.
But let me,
let me tell you,
it was so,
so Andy Galpin who you know.
Yes.
I talked to Andy Golf and,
and,
and a FIFA consume.
Who Does who?
Aubrey put me in touch with.
He uh,
he's the guy who coined the term the Gut biome should actually have on,
he's really,
really smart guy.
He's a scientist who's leading scientist in Gut biome.
They're working with the Cleveland Institute of Dermatology I think with
psoriasis.
So how the gut affects psoriasis.
So anyway,
long story short,
Andy got them,
puts me together with Dan Gardens,
got like 12 degrees,
but he a strengthen nutrition coach.
This mother fucker such a nerd with everything.
And this guy,
he,
I did as an gut analysis and all that stuff.
This guy gives me a diet and a and find some,
an opportunity,
an opportunistic infections and my gut bacteria that shouldn't be there.
He's got me doing like oil of Oregano and fucking um,
garlic pills and stuff like that.
But there's a whole regimen I do for four months.
Long story short,
then there's a probiotic protocol that you do.
I do all that.
My psoriasis just goes away.
It's just,
it has not come back and it's been gone now.
It's something I'll have to manage.
But when I say complete,
cause you saw my back.
Remember when you saw it?
It's all gone.
And I had that for nine months.
It got bad.
So somebody talked to Kim Kardashians,
just get that shit over.
There's overwhelming evidence that a lot of these owners of immune diseases are,
are somehow a gut issue.
You know how Jordan Peterson cleaning his up?
Yeah.
Carnivore.
Done.
Yeah.
And they think the corner carnival died.
It might be from what I've heard on your podcast and elsewhere,
is that,
I guess you,
you kind of give your gut bacteria a kind of a reset or,
or is it an elimination diet?
Yeah.
You take away virtually everything except one thing.
Your body adjusts and your body just somehow or another it secures itself have a
lot of ailments with an elimination diet and yeah,
well that's why.
That's what intermittent.
Controversial.
Yeah.
That is why in fasting in general it's so beneficial but helps me.
But the carnivore diet,
it's very fascinating because people fucking swear by it,
man.
There's people that they look great.
Their health is improved,
have lost weight and gain muscle.
All.
That's my question.
That is the question.
You need some fiber?
I don't think so.
I don't think you really do.
Most people that are taking it say they don't have any issues.
Some people have issues in the beginning of it,
but men,
people who have been doing it for years,
there've been doing,
they've been on the carnivore die for you.
Let Dr. Sean Baker,
he's been on it for years and you all eads is fucking rib eyes.
He just eats revise and eggs but aren't,
aren't the,
uh,
there are certain cultures that are a hundred percent carnival or like I think
the Masa traditionally where a lot of the,
a lot of the font to belt and Africa where,
where the Mohs I would great.
Oh yeah.
I've seen him in person.
I've been to Kenya twice.
I mean they look like professional athletes.
A full people.
Yeah.
I mean the turns of the effect on their body.
They don't look Mel nourish,
nourished rather.
There's six foot six.
There's no,
yeah.
My friend,
you know,
my friend lived with them for,
he's a pro triathlete and he lived with them for six weeks and uh,
he goes,
dude,
why?
I've been an athlete my whole life.
I'm not an athlete.
I tried to run with those guys.
I tried to do stuff with those guys and he's like,
the way they can like track shit.
He goes,
they could look at a blade of grass and the way it was bent or like a certain
area and go,
oh,
cuckoo.
Whenever they,
the fucking could do ran through here or whatever the fuck it was.
They could,
they could tell what kind of animal cancer.
Whoa.
And then it had this throwing contest.
They were throwing shit,
not just spears,
but they're throwing like this,
whatever it was.
And he said,
dude,
I could,
I was so embarrassed.
He was embarrassed.
He was just such a bitch.
It's like I have,
I have northern European bullshit genes.
These motherfuckers from Kenya,
you know,
it was a hold of this for sure.
It's really interesting that the cradle of civilization,
which is where all human beings emanated from Africa has the best jeans,
they have the best athletic genes when it comes to like physical performance.
Look,
since there's no denying to be off the coast.
I mean like Nigeria and that area that,
those,
that's a of Senegal bring up Senegal out that,
that,
what's that wrestling,
they call a,
I know what you're talking about.
Frank Grillo and on fight world did a,
he went to Senegal.
He goes,
dude,
six foot six.
I mean they all look like,
uh,
like that's what the NFL is made up of that and that guy wrote the sports gene,
Richard Bernstein.
I think sports illustrated writer said the fastest people in the world come from
that part of the world to be African coast.
That's where Jamaica,
that's where the slave trade had gone.
And,
and they,
they,
they came from that area so you can actually isolate the genes lambda.
Oh Wow.
This is interesting.
They're like pawn at each eyebrow and they're all giant.
Why did it,
why the fuck?
Huh?
Because they punched and they wrestle and they do great.
High Level Greco Shit.
Watch this is punching too.
And you'll say watch this high level Greco Shit.
They throw single ease wrestling,
indycar championship.
Beautiful.
It's La Luta is the um,
the title of the video.
Yup.
La Space.
L.
U.
T.
E,
single ease wrestling,
indycar championship.
Now they're working for position but,
and if you see some of these guys,
you see them,
what their bodies look like.
It's so good.
Just so ridiculous.
Like they live on fish and rice and be frank went there.
It's so poor.
And he said,
you just see dudes where you're like,
well,
if I had a body like that,
I would never wear clothes.
So I don't understand what they're doing here.
They're just getting coaching,
just getting positioned.
Whoever gets thrown.
Then these guys are rock stars in Senegal.
Okay.
They need coaching.
No.
You'll see none.
They punched me.
Tell you something.
Cain Valasquez shoots a power double on these mother fuckers back in the sand.
Sir,
I'm going to ask you to know.
That's true.
Five minutes.
I skipped.
I skipped ahead.
Five minutes.
Keep dead.
There's still waiting to patty cakes,
bro.
It's like sumo deuces nuts.
Oh,
exactly.
It's nonsense.
No,
excuse me.
Tread trip.
Oh,
they're punching each can't to shit,
dude.
This is serious.
Oh Shit.
They're punching from the clinch yam,
bro.
Wow.
This is fighting.
I said justice headband.
Yeah.
You've got to always adjust your van time.
Tom.
What is the time?
What did they do in time?
Time.
That's it.
That was the match.
No,
I maybe not called keep going with,
it's gotta be a better one that you got to see the heavyweights.
They heavy weights are the championship.
I figured that maybe it just sucks and you're really into it because it's
foreign.
Sir.
That's possible.
I'm telling you,
I've seen some incredible lamb.
Those dudes who play a petty case.
You will respect lamp.
Okay.
Kickbox and world champion.
Oh,
go to the far right one.
That one.
Okay,
there.
Here we go.
Now we'll see what's up.
Kickboxing world champion challenges.
Singling these wrestlers.
Who is this kickboxing world champion?
It's like a documentary.
I don't care.
I want to see who it is.
Not like there's got to find the fight.
Oh,
is it looking at other associates,
all sorts of stuff going on here.
Who's this kickboxing where he's like,
they're Sufi Muslim,
so they're hanging out with them very,
very spiritually.
Kickbox.
Okay.
Uh,
oral.
Say his name.
Brian.
Or learn or lean Duarte orally.
French,
multiple kickboxing,
Muay Thai and Chodo con karate champion.
That's like me.
So it looks like he's learning from these folks.
I don't think he's really challenging them.
Okay.
Let's see what happens in the,
there we go.
Look at it.
Look at my man right there.
Instead of saying still,
what does it say?
Sort of stand still.
Just let it go.
We'll see what happens here.
Other Breslin?
Yeah.
Oh,
so they're wrestling,
but it's all that dude.
Back up a little.
I'm gonna see that dude the kickbox and got interact with them.
There we go.
Okay.
Let's see.
Throws.
Okay.
They're just teaching him how to throw.
Oh,
they're teaching them some technique.
That's Kinda cool that they do it on the beach though.
That's smart.
That's a duck under it right there.
It took his back.
Yeah.
Nelson,
they know some wrestling techniques.
Wrestling is,
you know,
you could make the argument that wrestling,
would you say that wrestling is probably the best thing you could ever do coming
up if you want to get an MMA,
like to have the US?
Yes.
I think wrestling is the most important sport.
Yeah,
because you see guys like,
uh,
Camaros,
Guzman.
It was a perfect example.
Who was just on the podcast.
He's,
um,
another example of awesome African genes.
Um,
but he's,
he's a,
he's an excellent example of a guy who really didn't start striking at all until
like 2009 I mean,
but he's been watching how your body moves for Africa.
He mean he's been watching and fucking around,
but it doesn't matter like the way he strikes now you would think he's been
doing it his whole life and he's been only striking for 10 years.
I think wrestlers are just tougher.
You know?
C'Mon was saying that his needs are so fucked up for some of his fights that he
had to walk on grass cause it hurt to walk on concrete.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Really?
His daughter makes fun of him cause he goes down the stairs backwards.
Ah,
cause he goes downstairs.
Back.
Yes.
She thinks it's hilarious when I see him.
Like I saw with Rashad Evans and he looked as big as Rashad.
He's a big fella.
Yeah.
But here's the thing,
he couldn't be a nicer guy.
He's great.
He couldn't be a nicer guy.
And when you hear him talk on the podcast,
he's,
he's like,
he's so almost soft spoken.
He's easy going,
you know,
it's like,
it's weird that he's so good,
but in the way he describes it,
when he gets inside the cage of a switch gets flipped and he just becomes a
different person.
I felt like,
uh,
um,
all due respect to the great Tyron Woodley,
but he did,
he,
his body looks a little different and he looked a little bit,
um,
I don't know.
He didn't look as,
he didn't look the way he normally does.
[inaudible] see it.
I didn't see it.
And I look for that shit.
Looks like a car you go to.
I don't know about that man.
Go to a Tyron Woodley versus C'mon Huseman see if you could get a,
the video of the two of them right about the fight.
Why?
Why are you shaking your head so new?
I don't know if we can so new this happened.
So what?
It's not online yet.
That shit's online.
Everything's online.
You don't think it's online?
How much of my bed?
Just Oh,
why we cross right there,
I guess.
Well,
we don't have to show it like people are gonna show.
You guys show us.
Just show us.
People find it.
Go to,
you're going to have to go to ESPN for now on folks.
All fights are on ESPN.
All paper views.
ESPN.
Plus you have to get a subscription for ESPN plus if you want to get a paper
because that y'all,
yes,
yes.
Strange.
Yeah.
That's a good word.
Change is good words.
I love,
you know,
like I have certain favorite fighters of course.
I,
Ronnie,
I love Nick Diaz shorts,
but I,
Jorge Mazda at all.
It's a beast.
I just love,
I love like just a true fighter,
like an animal.
And he's so good.
He's so fucking good.
So smart.
Oh,
you're so smart,
man.
Clever changes it up.
Does things like you can't see what he's doing.
It's subtle.
He lives for fighting to really does.
Oh,
he's a fucking smart man.
There are men and then there's hard mosquito.
Just shows another label for sure.
He's on another level.
He's,
he's,
I think he's such a contender for,
I mean he just chewed.
He has 100% of the pretenders cowboy and then it takes two years out of the
octagon.
I don't know what,
he must have had an injury Darren till locked out Darren [inaudible].
I mean knocked him the fuck out.
I mean he hit him with that left hand a couple times early in the fight too.
He was doing some sneaky shit.
He was switching stances.
He was switching stances and throwing that left hand.
Yeah,
and he's throwing the right hand switching stances,
throwing the left hand and I think he's starting to read till point back and
like that and that's take,
then he finally through that right.
And then when he left he had caught him with that left hand several times.
Caught him in the first round and then call them in the second round.
He's a,
he's a bad motherfucker man.
He really is.
He's coming on soon too.
I'm going to have mom with Joey Diaz.
Moms would,
I was going to come home with Joey Diaz and get a little bit,
you may also be able to get knocked like that.
My Darren till who hits like a,
you know,
and come back and just regain his composure.
Punch of the fight.
It was the first punch of the fight now and smile the wine.
Yeah.
That's all right.
Let's do it.
He did the first move,
the fight he charges towards till and tries to side kick him in the thigh and
hits him in the Dick.
Yeah.
Like right away.
First shot right to the SAC.
Yup.
Yeah.
I love that guy.
I love,
I love Washington flight.
Well,
he's very crafty.
He's a real veteran.
You know,
I remember him knocking out,
uh,
Eve Edwards in Bodog fight.
Do you remember botox?
Botox?
You know,
Calvin Ayers's see some,
uh,
super millionaire playboy character who,
um,
he came up with this bow dog fight thing and it was back when you used to be
able to gamble online,
right.
You were able to gamble on line.
Now you can again,
but you used to be able to gamble online and a lot of businesses,
we're sort of constructed around the premise that online gambling was going to
be legal,
but through some bullshit finagling,
the federal government put the Kibosh on online gambling.
They put the stop on this thriving business and a lot of these companies,
like there was professional pool organizations like the IPT that went under
because they were counting on online gambling.
But Bodog was counting on it to,
cause he had like this online gambling website.
Well because of the online gambling shit.
He's like,
I don't want to say this,
I don't want to be incorrect because Dana White was saying that he's a fugitive
and he wasn't even allowed in the country.
But that's not too far removed from the truth.
I don't think he's allowed back in the United States.
I think he used to live in like,
you know,
just for providing service.
People wanted to be part of,
well,
for Duke,
for being a part of online gambling when it was illegal.
I think that's the issue.
Oh No,
it's fucking stupid.
I mean people,
you know,
let people do what they will.
I,
I think you should have,
it'd be cool if you could bet on fight Tyrone Woodley versus c'mon what was
done.
So I just would get more money and everything.
We'll see what tyrant loose man looks jacked.
Let's see what Tyron looks like when he gets into the cage.
T to me,
he looked exactly the same.
Let's see what happens when he takes his shirt off.
Hurry up time.
Right?
He's a beast.
Yeah.
I just don't think that was it,
man.
I mean,
you're also dealing with Tyron.
He's 37 now.
He is also in the middle of a,
he's in a transitionary stage in terms of his career,
so he doesn't look quite as checked.
Yeah.
But he's not mean.
He's not a tech based.
I mean,
you know,
it was pretty God damn good to me.
I mean,
he always does that.
I just see blood,
you know what I'm saying?
He's not like,
that's what I mean.
That's an,
I mean it was pretty good.
Hard to say.
Great fighter man.
Yeah,
he's 36,
I think he's 37 now.
He's also,
he's got a rap career now.
He was like opening for Wiz Khalifa.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He does a bunch of shit for TMZ now.
You know,
he's a busy man on top of the fighting.
He's smart.
Like that shit.
Get out of the fight game.
Yes.
He has nothing to prove.
Well he's one of those guys that can do that too.
He's a great talker.
Yeah.
He's uh,
he's,
he would be a great commentator if he decided to get into commentary and
percent,
but he wants a rematch,
you know,
I don't think he's happy with his performance and I think he thinks he could
have done better.
Trust me,
I just look like a bigger and a different way.
Class man.
Well,
it loose months.
Definitely Taller,
but I think even more importantly,
[inaudible] gas tank is just fucking,
it's,
well,
that's what's crazy antics.
And I feel like Tyron may have done a lot of cardio for that camp because he
knew he was going to have to deal with that.
So he looked,
he looked a little thinner than he normally.
Well,
Ooh.
Spawn just pushes the pace and he pushes the such a weapon.
Some guys can do that.
That's such a weapon.
Well he could do it for five rounds to men.
He doesn't get off the gas.
We were,
he was pretty honest too.
He's funny man.
When he was talking about the fourth round,
cause in the fourth round he had Tyron hurt and he poured the gas on,
just poured the gas on at tire and managed to survive.
And uh,
when Tyron managed to survive,
he was thinking to myself,
oh no,
what have I done?
But he recovered quick.
Yeah.
You know?
He does look a lot bigger though.
Huh?
Nice and long legs though in comparison.
In comparison,
you know,
also skinny legs.
John John's.
Exactly.
Jon Jon Jones.
You look at John Jones cafs only if you only saw his cash.
Weird.
And someone said to you,
all right,
is that guy in elite athletes like get the fuck out of here.
That guy's an accountant.
Exactly.
He's no way that,
that there are a lot of guys like that where you just don't judge a book by its
cover.
You'll go to sleep.
Yeah,
but Jon Jones is the Mo,
well his upper body,
obviously it's pretty strong.
Five.
I mean it's a different thing,
but he's got a farm,
phenomenal frame for combat sports cause he's got length,
but he's also has muscle.
I think that's the best frame.
I um,
I personally,
that's not real.
That's not real.
That's photo shopped assholes.
Real.
That's Photoshop.
Trust me.
Those are his calves.
Do.
Oh,
they're not that small.
Yes they are.
Those ankles don't even fit into his shoes.
He's got very skinny.
He has no gas.
But that last one was,
that's ridiculous that he set the one up.
There is a perfect one.
We're still in that kick right there.
How do you answer?
You can talk to you.
We'll look at it and plan for that terrible photo shopped.
They cut off the back of his leg there.
What are you talking about?
I don't know.
That's his leg.
No,
look at that.
That's his leg.
I don't think so.
That's 100% Photoshop.
You can see the blur on the Photoshop.
Why is that blurred?
Yes.
From a guy that does Photoshop every single day.
Yeah.
That's photoshopped.
You do Photoshop every single day.
What are you doing online?
I make our logo though.
I thought he'd doing weird shit.
Make me make the ended up photo and making me stronger.
Give Brian Abs.
I need to get down to it.
Let me see.
Uh,
well,
you know John is skinny calves point by saying,
um,
how do you defend against that terrible front kick to the fucking stomach every
time back?
Well,
he loves to throw it to the thigh,
to the,
he throws that oblique kick to the thigh and the sidekick to the knees.
You know,
all the,
it's interesting when I see people criticizing that can't come.
Like you're crazy that they,
they,
they're kicking people in the face.
You're,
you're,
you're mad that kicking him in the knee like,
oh,
you can ruin a career.
Like,
oh,
well you can't ruin a career by head kicking somebody.
Yeah.
Like Wonderboy was saying that about Darren till he thought Darren till was
trying to ruin his career or buy side,
kicking them in the knee and he doesn't like that technique should be legal.
Damn.
I came in,
I mean I get it,
but your head kicking people.
Yeah.
We'll kicked Jake Ellenberger in the fucking head.
How good is that for your career?
Not so good.
Come on,
man.
Brutal Sport,
It is.
It's as brutal as it gets man,
but it's not the worst thing for your body.
I think football's the worst cause some days he'll get hit like that.
Mustard.
I was another example of that.
I don't think I've seen him.
I don't know when.
The last time I saw him actually get cracked was he's so opening punch from
Darren till two mighty mouse or the best example.
Mighty mouse gets hit less than anybody,
but there's,
there's other guys that they're very hard to hit.
Y'All just get hit in practice though.
Yeah.
I know a lot of guys though,
who don't spark like that anymore.
I think Robbie Lawler stopped doing it.
I think cowboy,
I think a lot of these guys still,
I'll be stopped sparring completely for years while he's fighting for strike
force.
But then when he moved to a American top team,
he started sparring again and it was training really hard and that's when
actually he became the welter weight world champion.
He's,
he's so fucking tough.
And like I want to see that ask and fight again.
Cause he,
I put my money on Robbie Lawler that he does not care about.
He looked better than I've ever seen him cause he shape,
I've gone back and forth about five times on whether or not that was a good
stoppage,
but Huseman convinced me after we watched the footage that was a bad stoppage.
I think Robbie was okay.
I think,
uh,
he's just relaxed.
He was there.
He had what,
how,
I don't,
I mean,
how many more seconds,
but that bulldog jail time or,
but yeah,
but for Robbie Lawler,
I think he was all right.
But it's hard to tell.
It's just unfortunate.
And again,
herb dean is as good a referee as there is on planet earth.
There is no one better than him.
There's no one better.
Herb Dean is as good as it gets.
Yeah,
he made a mistake,
but it's hard to say if it was a mistake because I wasn't even sure it was a
mistake.
We were not sure if better than err on the side of caution because he couldn't
hear him.
He couldn't talk.
But here's the thing,
he's only getting choked out like if it's been aspirin,
it's only he's only get choked out if it's
Frances and gone.
No.
And he's fucking punching you in the head and you think your unconscious then
stopped the fight.
But if it's just a choke,
like Ben Aspirin is not known for being in any way,
shape or form a power striker.
No.
And he's not hitting them.
It's only holding onto his neck.
And I think that shows have been how tough bad ass Kronos cause he got his head
bounced off that fucking,
I was like,
you're getting crushed here and he's just like,
whatever.
I'm going to stick to my wrestling.
Yeah,
he was getting fucking pounded.
He figured it out and he,
even though the disengaged,
he managed to get ahold of Robbie again and get them on the ground and get that
choke on.
Yeah,
look,
it was,
it was fun while it lasted,
but he doesn't want to fight Robbie again.
I think if I was the UFC I would be absolutely trying to make that fight again.
Do you think that they will?
I think they want to.
That's what Dana White said that Ben said,
why would I want to do that?
I already went already one,
But the thing about,
you know,
uh,
Kamara was saying like,
you don't get a choice like the UFC.
He's going to tell you who to fight again.
Maybe they just offer Ben a good amount of money off from Robbie.
Robbie is,
uh,
you know,
he deserves that privilege and I think he's easily up there and he can always be
the champion again cause he looks as good.
He looks as good as he's ever looked.
It looked amazing.
You look amazing physically.
He looked amazing when he was fighting.
Even more importantly,
I think that's the fight that makes the most money because people want to see
that.
I want to see it.
You want to see it all the real fans want to see it.
Yeah.
I think I don't do enough of that in USA.
They do sometimes,
but when I was going to say is like that,
he deserves it,
but Jesus,
no one deserves it more than Steve Bay Meo Church.
Steve Bay loses to DC and we haven't heard hide nor hair of them.
He's the fucking most successful heavyweight of all time.
He defended the title four times.
No one's ever been able to do that.
He does that and he gets nothing after that.
No love,
no respect,
no nothing to Kratom.
No talk about him fighting DC again.
You know,
they're just talking about DC Brock Lesnar and they don't even know Brock lasers
is really gonna fight,
isn't it?
DC kind of retired though.
DC once a fight.
Brock,
he's got a fight,
Brock and he's going to retire.
He's going to just kind of get that to me.
To me the most,
the most impressive fighter to ever step in the octagon is Daniel Cormier.
You certainly one of them.
I've just hit intern housing more impressive when when Jon Jones beat him
because,
well,
so John Jones is without a doubt the most talented and best fighter.
To me with the tools that DC's working with when you're five,
nine,
five,
10 and you,
you know,
you just,
you're dealing with guys with so much taller,
with so much more reach,
know he's undefeated as a heavyweight.
The only man he's ever lost to was John Johnson.
Everybody else,
all commerce steep payment.
Just give me a number and he takes,
he's taking every one of them out.
Listen,
I'm a giant fan.
Just incredible.
Don't get me wrong,
it just shows you how good Jon Jones,
Jon Jones has his number,
whatever the case.
But it's both.
I'd like to see DC fight Jon Jones at heavyweight,
me to two 40 that might happen.
That might be the big fight.
The big fight might be if DC fights Brock,
let's assume he beats Brock,
which I think you would then DC fights Jon Jones.
Yeah.
But he might not be Brock.
Here's the thing about Brock,
and this is so ridiculous to say.
He still a fucking giant Viking human.
Yeah.
He's so extraordinarily big.
He's so powerful that if he clips DC,
anything can happen.
Yeah.
But he's got,
he's going to get punched in the face by DC and I think,
I personally believe that if you are not getting punched in the face and working
on patterns and really working on your striking,
you get into the ring with a guy like Daniel Cormay who does that every day.
True.
But we don't get all the and the jaw.
We don't know that that's the case.
We also know that he has been wrestling with this,
a Michigan state wrestler that's one of the best wrestlers on the planet earth.
This video of him wrestling with this current phenom and he's training with like
real elite world chest fighters.
But you're wrestling when he's doing with his striking.
Yeah,
but Daniel Cormier has got that down and he's also,
Brock has also the WWE champ,
Bro.
I don't know if you know there is that strong people around there is that got
hit with a chair?
You're right.
I don't know man.
I mean all my money on DC,
I would say that DC would be heavily favored.
Yeah.
I would also say that that big gorilla can fucking punch any person on the
planet with those lunchbox fists and you're fucked.
He's so big,
man.
When you stand next to Brock,
he just like,
oh,
you're a total east silver back.
Yeah.
He's as close to a silver back because I've ever seen is a viking.
A long arms.
Giant human.
Yeah.
Ridiculous fists.
The the real question is,
I mean how much has he really been working on is striking in in these years that
he's been outside of the cage,
how much does he,
much easier to work on your wrestling if you're him than it is striking.
Striking is a whole different animal.
Well,
particularly spark,
not just like hitting Mitts and hitting the pad,
but getting,
getting good rounds and against people that can crack and people that can crack
like DC where he clinches you and then hits you in the clinch and also learning
how to adjust.
Like the great fighters that I noticed are guys who,
they come in with a game plan,
that game plan gets shut down and then they change it up.
Right.
Then they do subtle things.
They just start doing little differences and you got all your,
you're doing,
you're doing a whole different thing here and that guy can't see it or a lot of
people can't to end.
That's what I think is amazing.
Then there's the other thing,
he's got to get off the sauce,
so he got,
he got off the sauce,
so if he gets off the sauce now he's 40 and he's been on Mexican supplements for
the last few years for sure.
Yeah,
and your whole endocrine system is just like,
wait,
what's going on?
Hey [inaudible] good luck.
Yeah.
I mean who knows?
Who knows?
I'm going to,
I'm going to have to get myself on some,
I'm looking forward to get onto charity.
I don't feel like I need it yet.
Be on a right now.
Really.
It should be done in a long time ago.
You think so?
100%,
but telling you forever.
I know,
I know.
I want to,
I want to keep squeezing every little ounce of natural juice.
Well,
it's real.
I mean,
you,
you can do it without it,
but you won't be as healthy.
You won't be as strong.
We won't have as much energy.
The real,
you got some energy.
Yeah.
The best thing would be if they could figure out a way to revitalize your body's
natural production of testosterone.
That's,
that's similar to the way it is when you're a 30 year old man.
They could really do that right now.
The camp,
you know right now,
you can only add it.
You can,
you can get your,
it put it.
There's a lot of other stuff going on.
Like if you listen to that,
um,
the podcast that I did with,
what's the doctor's name?
That anti aging doctor.
Oh,
David's David Sinclair.
Yeah.
Um,
there's a lot of factors.
You know,
there's a lot of different things that you can do and mn,
resveratrol,
all these different things that I want those things.
I want to m and m and m and what is an m?
N It's telomere along gators.
Linkedin's you're telling me,
she's telling me the best sign of the telomeres.
Get Google the actual definition of telomeres,
but it's a the best sign of whether or not your body's aging.
Correct.
Resveratrol.
Um,
you get online.
Yeah.
That little container out there.
You could take that if you want.
I got shit loads of it.
Yeah.
I got a lot of it.
I want to live forever.
Yeah.
When he told me about it,
I started taking it every day.
I take it every day with my morning vitamins pretty in a lot of meat you have.
He says no,
I don't listen to him.
He also says to take,
uh,
I listen to him when it's convenient to me and I'll tell him.
He is also called Terra mail telling me or terminal transfer ASE is an enzyme
made of protein and RNA subunits that long gates chromosomes by adding t t a,
G,
O triple g sequences to the end of existing chromosomes.
Tell him,
tell him.
Morays is found in fetal tissues,
adult germ cells and also tumor cells.
The result of aging cells in an aging body,
so just slows down aging.
I'll tell you what,
man,
that NMN stuff,
it makes me feel great.
It does 100% yeah,
it gives me a lot of energy.
Really?
Yeah.
How about kitten?
Oh,
Bri.
Some.
I'll get you some.
Yeah,
unless you want me to die faster.
No,
I love you.
All right,
well look.
Hey,
get me some fucking,
let's go.
Let's you want me to dive?
I mean,
I was just going to get you TRT verse 10 years.
I got on it 10 years ago and I was telling you,
dude,
you should be honest.
Like I'm good,
I'm good.
I know I'm still nervous about it,
but I'm going to do some tests.
Nervous about,
I want to get thick.
I people like this.
I want to go like that.
I want to go and date and jump off a building and glide to the fucking ground.
You want to look at something like that?
You got a nice body.
Let's go ahead and lose that shit.
Let's get you moving around in the corner over there.
They're scared.
Um,
yeah,
I wish there was a way to do it naturally and I think there's going to be,
I think they're going to be able to do it through some sort of gene manipulation
that the little turn on your bus there,
there is so close to doing this to mice where they're literally reversing the
age of a mouse and Sinclair was talking about this and I've had some
conversations with some other people that are really deeply entrenched in the
world of genetic engineering and um,
and CRISPR and all,
all the,
the new innovations there.
They're going to be able to do that.
It's a matter of when,
I think when we're 80,
it's,
there's a high probability the,
by the time you and I are 80,
you're going to be able to be 20 again.
Come on.
I'm,
I'm not bullshit.
Come on.
No,
I think that's real dude.
I want,
I want there's that gene that people can get just five hours of sleep,
that wakefulness thing.
Um,
as in 3% of the population it's called Adderall.
Yalla there's that tip says that too.
But there's one gene that is,
yeah,
that where you can act and why we sleep.
He was talking about it but also,
um,
my friend has that gene does genome and the,
I don't let you have that gene frank Grillo cause you'd have that gene.
Cause I know he doesn't sleep at all.
And I'm always like,
how do you sleep five hours?
He goes,
I just wake up and he's fully awake and he works out for fucking two hours and,
and I've,
I've only met one of the dude like that and that's a gene that's vanishingly
rare.
And some people had can can get five to six hours of sleep,
five hours and achieve total wakefulness.
They're going to be able to do that.
Yeah,
they're going to be able to manipulate your eyesight with germs.
They're going to be able to inject you with a germ that repairs your eyesight.
What's going on with this pitch?
Can't wait.
You See,
Francisco neurology professor using Hue Food Phd discovered the mutation of the
gene d c to any family of natural short sleepers people who go to bed at a
normal time.
11:00 PM midnight.
He usually wake up naturally at 5:00 AM.
I wonder if Jocko has that shit.
These are not.
I think he just gets up with pure hate that now.
He probably has that gene.
I don't believe that.
Self Control,
discipline and self control last only so long.
Wish she was right next to you.
Change your tune.
It starts sucking his dick.
Jocko is kind of tough,
terrifying black belt in Jujitsu.
Hundred and 40 pounds.
Serial killer that thick.
I didn't know he's that big.
Oh my God.
Oh,
Jesus.
Tacos a tank.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
Dude.
He's an inch taller than me anyways.
240 pounds.
You don't know what Jocko was a fucking white Samoan to Jocko taps.
Dean lister and training.
What?
Yes.
You don't understand what you're talking.
Oh,
he's at freezing gorilla.
Yeah,
he is looking at him.
Yeah.
He said it was that picture of him with his shirt off.
Some men are just men.
Does that hit click on it?
That's it.
No,
that's not him.
Yeah,
he's a gorilla dude.
That's stupid.
It's getting into bow hunting.
You should too.
Yeah,
he's a killer.
Don't you want to be a born warrior?
Yeah.
I went pheasant hunting when my boy Tarik and his brother.
Fun.
Right and blast flushing pheasant.
Huh?
It's cook the pheasants pheasant.
Oh,
that's right.
You told me in Napa and Sonoma.
Oh my God.
Next time you come out we'll go.
Okay.
My Boy Tarik has got it locked down.
We eat.
We shoot pheasant and you eat the best president.
Drink the best wine.
There's nothing better and smoke cigars and hang out.
Tell me a better time.
Tell me about Jake's buddy Jake.
Yeah.
Jake shields.
Buddy.
Jake said he corners chick Tarik Tarik Hazeem teaches me boxing.
Aye.
He's got this incredible Jim called empower.
I go there in San Francisco.
I go to San Francisco.
Just collect.
Hang on.
Is this you guys?
That would be me running.
Oh,
getting cardio.
Did you have a dog to fetch the birds or did German short hair.
Oh my buddy.
Tarik Azeem and shout out to,
why are you running with a gun though?
Dude?
Cause I get my cardio in a loaded gun.
Don't mustache that you look like you have a sets right now.
Are you growing one?
Nah.
I just got to think in a show there,
bro.
It seems like you're dancing with us and dude,
I just,
I grow hard.
I grow hard if I could,
if I take a poo and I push hard,
I grow a mustache.
Hm,
interesting.
Yeah.
Do you try?
Nah,
it just,
it just happens.
I like being manly.
I like shooting pheasant and by the way that you flush them and then they fly up
and they're about six feet in front of you and we were still missing still
fucking course.
It's so annoying.
I went pheasant hunting once with Bordain.
Oh you did?
Yeah,
I shot one in the feather.
I shot,
it's feather blue,
a piece of its feather off and it flew away.
Laughed at me pro took a shit in my general direction.
I like caught off one shot.
Look,
public land hunting is hard.
You know,
most of the hunting that I do is on private land.
It's public land hunting.
A lot of pressure,
a lot of people out there doing it,
you know?
Well,
animals get smart.
Well they get in,
there's the argument,
there's two arguments and I support both of them.
One argument is it public land hunting is harder and you should really be more
proud of success on public land because it's for everybody.
It's not an elitist thing.
It's very difficult to do.
You've got to really put in the work.
Yeah,
you got to have discipline.
I get that argument,
but my,
the problem that I have with it is,
first of all,
I don't have a lot of time and I liked success,
but to the animals,
when they're pressured,
they don't act normal.
They don't call as much like elk,
elk in particular event in a high pressure areas.
Problem with wolves,
wolves moving to areas.
The elk just shut down all the calling.
One of the coolest things about elk hunting is they fucking scream.
One,
the first time I ever went elk hunting with campaigns,
we took me elk hunting.
Uh,
I remember this morning we're out there in this base and you hear just boy,
you hear him screaming and it's still dark out and we're walking in like,
this is the fucking coolest thing I've ever heard in my life.
Just hearing them scream and yelling at each other and trying to fight off the
other males.
And you hear their,
their horns clashing against each other because their antlers are,
they're there,
they're fighting.
And this is on public land or is this,
this was on private land.
Yeah.
Cause I,
I,
this is for me a lot of that hunting and we needed to do it again,
by the way.
Yeah,
I don't,
it's not so much about killing the animal.
I,
it's the comradery.
Like,
like so I'm on this,
they stock this field with these pheasant.
I'm not there to kill the fest and I loved the meats and stuff and,
but,
but it's more the experience with my two friends and we're out there with a dog.
I like to say that too,
but I like to kill elk.
Oh,
to eat.
I like the food.
I liked the meat.
Yeah.
I live off elk.
You check my DNA.
It's 65% el kindly to Mel.
I'm not bullshitting.
I eat so much of it.
I feel focused.
Great.
I bet.
I mean,
I think there's something to it.
I did too.
It's what I say.
I need a lot of it.
I'm meeting this dark red protein.
That's good.
It's coming from these fuck when I have animals that are dodging mountain lions
and it's good for you.
Yeah.
You take the life force of the animal into your man.
There's something about that.
I swear to God and even the pheasant,
like you know,
it's,
there's just something,
there's something about looking for an animal that focuses your mind and even in
something as lame as when they're roosting on a field.
You've got the dog and the dog points.
It's exciting.
And fishing.
I had such a,
what's that?
You look fishing.
I don't,
I'm not a good Fisher.
I'm sure if I learned how to fish,
but fishing is technique.
We tried to know I grew up fishing.
Oh you did?
Yeah,
I was real.
I was in the Bass Angler Sportsman society like 13 years old.
You're a competitive warranty,
you know,
I mean I just like to fish.
Yeah.
I mean competitive by friends,
you always want to catch the biggest fish.
But there's something about fishing,
man.
There's something about casting align and the best to me is like a top water
bait.
Like you cast a plug and you see it land on the water pauses,
the ripples sort of spread out and then you'd give it a twitch,
give it another twitch and you let it pause again.
And then a big explosion of water.
It got that mother fucker like,
Oh shit dude.
My little daughter,
my youngest is hundred percent hooked on fishing.
Really?
She got a six pound bass in Florida.
Yeah,
man,
it keeps me out to no end because she's my little fishing buddy.
Like we were,
we were in Maui and when we were in Maui we went,
um,
we went hunting or hunting.
We went and caught a yellow tail and she caught out gang,
a yellow tail and this little tiny girl,
like a 10 pound yellowtail is a mother fucker to try to reel in.
There is so hard to reel in.
And she was reeling him in on her own man.
I mean,
all I had to do is hold the rod because it literally would have yanked the rod
out of her hands.
I'm trying to show you a picture that's okay.
I've got a picture in here somewhere.
Take my daughter fishing.
Dude.
It's fun man.
And then,
you know,
with,
with the Bass,
we'd let them go.
Okay,
here's,
here's her with a six pound bass.
Perfect.
Look with the,
with the Bass,
we let him go.
It was a catch and release deal.
Um,
but the yellow tail,
we ate that that night.
So the whole family ate something that she called.
That's good.
She loved,
that's huge.
So excited by it.
She got,
so she just,
she beams with pride.
It's this little tiny girl.
Yeah.
You know,
and she's holding onto this,
right?
She would not let me reel it in.
She's like,
do you want me to,
I go,
do you want me to real an answer?
No,
she had two hands on it going to get us cranking and I'm holding onto it and she
made sure she pulled it into the boat too.
Like she's obsessed.
It's awesome.
I love that.
I think once you've felt what it's like to catch a fish and then cook it and eat
it once.
And by the way,
if you never had really fresh fish,
it's really fresh.
Fish is so flavorful and delicious and just a little bit of butter and lemon on
it.
And since it's a little bit of seasoning and I've done that plenty of times.
I've gone on organize fishing,
deep sea fishing.
You know what we should do?
We should organize a Gig in Alaska in July during the salmon runs a great idea.
We'll do a gig up there and got to encourage,
we'll catch some salmon for a few days,
do a Gig to pay for the whole trip.
Just have a good time.
Ari and I did that a few years and I love to do that.
Dude,
Ari and I did that and we caught some giant salmon.
Let's do that.
We caught some king salmon.
They were like 30 pounds was amazing.
Wow.
I ate salmon for fucking months.
Jesus.
Yeah.
I love that.
So fun.
I'd love to do that,
but you know what's fucked?
The mosquitoes,
it's crazy.
The worst.
Never seen anything like it.
It's like an assault.
Yeah.
It's like a gang violence in Indonesia.
When I,
when I,
when I was tracking orangutans and the rainforest,
I was 21 or whatever and I thought I wanted to be a naturalist.
Yeah,
right.
I love that story.
About the ants.
Oh Dude,
fuck,
forget the ants.
You had to carry a sulfur coil because bug repellent didn't work on those
mosquitoes.
You had to carry around a sulfur coil.
Look at that.
That's already in the salmon.
Could I the Queen afterwards?
Fucking Santa Grand Jewish.
How doors as a big ass salmon.
Yeah,
it is.
Is there any more pictures of our fish?
One picture.
There's one other thing,
but I didn't check that.
That was a big ass fish though.
Look at Ari.
Handsome bastard.
Yeah,
it's fun man.
I love fishing.
I really wish there was a place click close to my house where I could fish.
It's very peaceful,
you know like fish for your breakfast.
Catch a trout.
Yeah.
And then you know cook that motherfucker in a pan right there on the shore.
Oh,
it's incredible.
So known to have a lot of,
and people want to haunt him.
Like Justin Napa Valley,
a shitload of mountain lion hunt them though.
Now they're everywhere though.
Apparently too many of them.
There was a real dump thing because they do hunt them,
but they hunt them with a professional hunters.
At the state has to hire because they get depredation permits because they start
killing livestock or dogs or what.
I grabbed a Lama when I'm glad a Llama and jumped over the fence with the Lama
in its mouth.
Yeah.
I mean that's fucking nuts.
You can't do that then.
No crazy.
I train but you,
but even if you train,
he put it on your back.
Let's see.
Let's,
if you put a a lama
in a backpack,
say you got like a fucking Cafaro backpack.
Good luck stuffed the in there.
You had the whole lobby zipped it in,
had it.
Okay.
Go over that fence.
He'd be like,
well my buddy who was a guide in Alaska,
my buddy Chad,
he said that they were climbing up this mountain.
It was a fucking nightmare.
Like they'd like just slogging up this steep mountain just like,
and they were like looking up and they're like,
God damn,
this is a nightmare.
You know,
you're making like inches.
Just like,
Oh and you got a backpack and it just like,
when is this going to be over?
And don't try not to think about it.
Let's take a break,
you know,
and they just hear this and they just see this grizzly with an elk in its mouth
and it just bounds up the mountain.
It just goes Shagun Shagun right by them with,
uh,
with an open its mouth and just goes up over the mountain and over the ridge,
just no problem in 12 seconds.
And they were like,
well,
that's a grizzly.
That's how strong a fucking girls face.
And this is me,
Jesus Christ.
I don't want to get,
that's,
I'm so terrified of,
I'm terrified.
I don't want to fuck get fucked up by a chimpanzee.
A chimpanzee will eat my face and my boss.
So I don't want that.
And I definitely don't want to get attacked by a grizzly because they'll start
eating you when you're still alive.
And that's a problem.
Most of the time grizzlies
eat people though,
or most time of grizzlies kill people.
They're not killing someone because they want to eat them,
right?
They're killing someone because you startled them and they're with their female,
the females with their cubs.
So that's the most.
So what happens when,
what are you supposed to do when a grizzly just pray?
Well,
if it's a female grizzly,
you are literally better off letting her fuck you up,
right?
It just curl up in a ball.
You're supposed to put your hand behind your neck,
lay in a fetal position and don't let her get access to your organs cause she
wants to chew your Oregon's apart.
Yeah.
It's one of the reasons why it's really important to have a strong backpack.
He was strong backpack.
She'll fuck up that backpack while you're on,
on your,
you know,
on your knees,
curl up in a fetal position,
but that's assuming you can survive that she's probably going to break your
arms.
She's probably going to snap your legs bite into you in ways that you can't
imagine the kind of force and power she can generate.
She's trying to immobilize you.
She wants to mobilize you as a threat to her children.
But a male,
if a male is trying to kill you,
it's usually because he's starving to death.
They don't recognize people as a food source,
so they rarely people.
So that mail PR,
it probably has never eaten a person.
It's one of the reasons why it's safer to be in a place where they hunt
grizzlies.
Cause in a place where they hunt grizzlies,
the grizzlies,
he's a person,
he goes,
fuck this,
they'll smell you and get the fuck out of there.
Right.
But like Yellowstone,
they haven't hunt grizzlies there and forever.
So people still get jack.
They're still,
they get jack or every couple of years.
So it gets killed.
You should,
but you might not be able to get to it and you also have to be prepared to pull
it out and shoot quickly.
You can't think that just because you have a gun,
you're going to be okay.
No,
because you don't hear him coming up on,
you come up so fast.
They move so fast.
They run,
they fast as a dog and they're huge.
That's true.
Yes.
There they run fast as fuck man.
And they're huge means a giant animal.
That 800 pounds.
Think about that.
Sure.
That's just stumbled across a story about this just happened.
Bear spray didn't work and it was attack and the guide and the,
the,
the client went to grab the glock out of the pack and it didn't fire.
And then the bear came after him.
So he tried to throw the gun to the other guy and then it didn't a deck I just
ran.
And I guess that's how follow the died and who died.
It doesn't say,
I don't,
I didn't find out.
I mean it happens all the time.
Yeah.
The best story is Rinella story,
uh,
Rinella and Remy Warren and is Fatalis and uh,
our friends,
they uh,
they got attacked while they were in a fog neck island in Alaska.
Yeah.
Yes.
Like two years ago.
And Remy came on here and told the story and it's fucking terrible.
God,
what happened?
Well,
they killed an elk and um,
they had hung it in a tree and they had taken some of the meat back cause you
know,
you have to hike out a fog.
NAC is particularly dense.
It's very,
very dense.
Vich like,
remember when we were on Prince of Wales island when we went on that dense.
Dense,
yeah.
Well,
it's like that,
but even worse.
And Grizzlies everywhere.
Yes.
Grizzlies everywhere.
Where was a huge problem with that?
When we were on an island that island had black bears.
Yeah.
Which weirdly enough,
they're not as dangerous,
but they are more predatory towards people.
I want a giant spike Telmate and spiked collar and I want my guns like clothes
closed.
Won The iron man suit.
That's right.
I want to be able to correct shoot rockets out of my hands.
And I want to be able to electrify it when the,
when the thing bites,
yes.
Kill it and then immediately cut its head off and put it on a steak so all the
other grizzly bears known not to fuck.
That's exactly right.
Right.
Okay.
There you go.
We're on like a man.
Yeah,
we definitely need to go on a hunt again.
I know,
Dude.
It's so much fun.
Yeah.
Even if a,
if it's a rifle hunt,
I'll go on a rifle hunt.
You,
you just love bow hunting.
Huh?
I love you.
Bought me a bow.
I need,
I was going to bring it to the tells you.
You shoot it shot and I wanted to apply your boat three years ago.
I know you a new one
comes out with new models every year.
I liked that one.
I haven't,
I've never shot.
It's great bow.
So let me,
let me get used to that one.
Not become expert.
Well,
um,
what I would like you to do,
honestly,
what I'd like to do,
and we should organize this with John.
Oh,
John Dudley,
because we have access to the,
literally the best archery coach on the planet earth in John Dudley.
He's the best.
He's so good when he's,
first of all,
he's a world.
He was a world class competitive archer.
Look,
he competed on the world stage who traveled all throughout the planet.
But so what is his like what are the principles he teaches?
Well,
first of all,
it's just like martial arts.
If you have a bad coach,
you'll develop bad technique and it's going to be very difficult for you to
learn.
You can still excel.
Some People Still Excel with bad coaching,
you know,
there's people that have just a natural ability to fight,
right?
And you teach them,
you just a few things,
they know how to like put knuckles to your face.
Some people are just better at that and they just,
they have a good mentality for it,
but they would be way better if there were with for Rasa Hobby,
they would be way better if they're with Duke Roufus there's just no doubt about
it.
Great Coaching is imperative for achieving your full potential and percent.
That's the same thing with archery.
With archery.
A guy like John Dudley,
we'll put the fundamentals in the perfect position for you and he changed my
archery so much that like I had been doing archery for more than a year or so
before I met him.
Maybe a year and a half.
My,
my whole,
uh,
my ability jumped up 20 to 30% within the first couple hours of meeting him.
Wow.
Yeah.
What 100%.
Geez,
you got video of me and him and my backyard and I'm laying these nocturnal Aero
Knox.
They lit Knox.
So they fly through the air,
it looks like laser beams and I'm laying them into my elk target at like 65
yards.
Just thunk,
thunk,
thunk all of them going into the vitals.
So boxing is like that.
Oh,
I had uh,
Donald Serani one time.
Just sit there and explain to me like where to place my feet and what I was
doing wrong and why more way should be on my back foot.
But just little things like that or my buddy Tarik all,
I'm weighing the Calico of course who I train with,
but,
but my boy Tarik like he'll teach me stuff that,
it comes from that MMA background,
but just where,
where you're looking like how to judge distance and there are certain techniques
to do it or just where your back foot should be in relation to that person's
foot regarding,
you know,
they're just how to set things up and they can,
some people can simplify it and teach it as basic principles were like,
Damn Damn,
it makes such a huge difference.
A huge difference.
Sure.
You know,
I mean,
there's ways to do things correctly and people have spent their entire life
learning these things and learning how to teach these things too,
which is critical.
You know,
theirs look like we both came from a taekwondo background and I got very,
very,
very fortunate in that the school that I found that I stumbled into,
Jay Kim taekwondo and do in Boston was one of the best gyms on earth.
I just got super lucky.
So I learned from the time I was a young kid,
I learned the right way to do things and the emphasis was always on technique.
Yep.
It,
it didn't matter how fast you were,
if you were doing it wrong,
you were corrected.
The Russians are like that.
Like there's this tennis woman in,
in Moscow who's responsible for the tennis revolution,
Sharapova and all those people,
and she is a coach who,
she's like 77 she's got like two courts and the kids,
when they get there,
I don't think they're allowed to really hit a ball for the first six months.
I mean,
there's swing your swing and you're,
you're positioning.
She ingrains those fundamentals so that you can't do it wrong.
So before you start playing tennis,
you are ingraining,
uh,
neural pathways and patterns
that are perfectly correct so that when the shit hits the fan,
you get emotional.
You don't know how to do it wrong.
You don't know how.
Right,
right,
right.
I think virtual hunter and those guys do the same thing when they train.
You know,
like when you went very long.
I'm sorry.
Virtual hell no,
but,
but hunter who is,
um,
who's,
uh,
Andre Ward's coach virtual though,
isn't that right now?
I think it's personal hunter look that up.
But,
but,
but what they'll do is that original hill was the light heavyweight champion
that Roy Jones Jr and knocked out with a body shot.
Um,
I think his coach,
but version of those,
I've been talking to Andre Ward on the Instagram to get ahold of him.
Such a mass.
Get Him in here.
He's,
he's not just a mastery.
So brilliant analyst too.
He's,
he's amazing.
But he was trained where the discipline of of fundamentals and perfecting your
technical hunter.
Yeah.
First of all,
hunter,
can you listen to Virgil Hunter?
I've,
I listened to him the way he speaks and uh,
I just,
I obsess over over that.
Like I love watching the old school guys.
This has got coach Anthony who I watch his videos on Youtube.
I think he's in Kansas City by the way.
I'd love to get in there and train with him,
but he's,
he's a guy who like breaks shit down in those little details and you just
realize what a science boxing is and you realize like it was that awesome Eddie
Teddy House thing you did where he goes,
his boxer like you're making mistakes but then there are mortal,
like you're making sins but you're making mortal sins like getting hit with
shots you don't see.
He can teach you how to avoid that.
Yeah.
And that's a little detail and everything in life is that way.
It's like you want to be really good at something,
get great coaching and it's those small adjustments that make all the
difference.
Like the bed,
that was the number one,
the a hundred a hundred tennis player in the world.
And the number two tennis player in the world is that much,
but it's all the difference in the world.
Yeah.
Um,
learning how to do things correctly in every single discipline is the most
important thing.
Yeah.
Learning how to do it correctly.
And then from there,
all your creativity and all your ability to improvise all comes from these
perfect fundamentals.
That's right.
Did you watch Earl spins?
Junior miking Garcia and I did not and I want to see Earl Spence.
He just looks so much bigger than Michael Garcia.
A lot bigger.
I want to see her.
I'll Spence and Mr. Crawford go at it.
Oh,
me too.
That's going to be,
that's going to be a big fight.
I just felt like Mike Garcia,
who I love,
I'm going to watch it,
but he,
he just looked so much smaller and rural.
Spence hits too hard.
He won't look bigger.
He won't look that much bigger than Terrence.
Terrence Crawford is about is he's,
he's a guy who changes things up,
man.
Always thinking that he'll come out and fight the first five rounds of the
southbound.
You think you got them figured out and then they'll switch stances and fuck you
up.
That that kind of genius,
that Kinda high fight Iq is crazy.
What's also that ambidextrous ability is so critical.
I mean,
that was Marvin Hagler.
Marvin Hagler used to switch back and forth and no one,
you couldn't do Jack Shit about it.
He would fight you as a southpaw,
just as good as you'd fight you orthodox and he didn't know what the fuck coming
next there is.
Taran could do that.
There was add fighter who said,
I can't,
he's reading my mind because he's reading my mind.
He goes,
what?
he knows what I'm gonna do before I do it.
Well.
Well,
Duran understood those patterns so well.
He could,
he could just,
he'd just cuts you off.
He just be like,
oh,
I know what you're going to do.
I can see already what you're setting up before you do it.
Yeah.
That's like Jujitsu.
You know your role with someone who's really good.
They know watch tenor Gracelyn way before you're going to do it.
I watched Henna Gracie Take Brendan Shop Lit.
I'm a cheetah.
I mean all these guys,
these killers,
I was like,
I was,
he was starting on his back and they're on top of him and he wouldn't choke them
out.
I was like,
what?
Yeah,
he lets them take us back.
But,
but again,
he's so far ahead of them.
He knows what you're going to do so he can cut you off.
It's like every hair tie.
I tried to move around with Wayne McCullough,
like he'll just,
he just,
no matter what I'm doing,
I'm doing the winky right thing.
I'm keeping my hands here.
I'm like,
there's no,
and he just finds your face and he's touching you.
And it's like everything right along that things get you get better at
everything.
I mean,
like you know that feeling that you get when you watch someone who's only been
doing standup like a year and you see them going on in front of a crowd and you
see them choking up panicking and maybe rushing a joke or being awkward.
I have to run away.
Yeah,
man,
it's weird.
But then ladies and gentlemen,
here's your next comic.
Brian Cowen.
Yeah,
just go up and just loose and relaxed.
You've seen it all before,
but I do,
but this is what I like.
What I like is that there are all these things that you can do like that where
you just get better.
If you keep doing it,
you learn more.
I think learning things and there's an art to learning.
There's an art to learn,
but I think it's so critical to enjoying life.
I think that's one of the like learning stuff and doing difficult things.
We can see incremental improvement that's that's based on your effort and your
concentration.
I think these are really important for happiness.
100% like think about all of our friends that are really happy that we're all
pursuing things.
Also,
I know where to place my energy and I can see myself getting better,
but more importantly I can,
not only do I see myself getting better,
but I can.
I come to understandings when I'm writing standup now when I'm thinking of what
my next,
my next one hours going to be,
I I'm,
I start kind of like getting to what I think about an essence,
like where am I right now?
I've kind of arrived at a place.
I set these goals for myself and now what?
Now what?
Now I've got to stand still.
Maybe what the fuck does that look like?
Well,
I'm going to write about that.
I'm going to write about not,
not my life has been either a fight or I'm not.
I'm ready to run away,
right?
Just choke about not wearing moccasins and I had this therapist a wore
moccasins.
I was like,
I don't trust somebody who wears moccasin mock something really good for
stalking the year either.
I was going to say the only time a mock moccasin is macho as if you're sneaking
up on a castle guard to take them out with a knife or your hunting deer.
That's the only time.
Otherwise we're a cult leader and you're selling your cock.
I have,
you know what I mean?
Paris mock saying,
well,
I don't trust you unless you've got a bone in your hand.
If you come out with her
moccasins and you're smiling,
you're trying to fuck bought.
A new pair is bottle.
Yeah.
All right.
Well good.
Just for stalking.
I like
to see you.
Don't break any twigs.
I'm here.
Well,
you want on your fucking phone to be able to walk like this.
You want to be able to walk?
Yes.
Well,
when I was in,
when I was in Indonesia and my Dayak guides,
the indigenous people of Indonesia didn't break a twin under their feet.
Bare feets her bare feet in feet for great.
The in the rain forest for no problem.
Cooties.
I'd hunt with bare feet.
You got,
you got leeches.
You got spiders.
They didn't get by.
He ain't,
I'm worried about snakes and girls.
US of us.
Well,
you should be.
Yeah,
especially warm months.
The last scene when here
she's,
fuck man,
I've never been bitten,
but I've had my dogs bitten three times.
The Frank.
Yeah.
Frank got bitten three fucking times.
Franklin,
Lucy,
they both got bitten.
You have to get him.
I'm going to bring him to the fucking doctor.
One time I brought him to the doctor,
the doctor looked at him,
says,
well,
I don't see any swelling.
The mind,
it might not have gotten them cause he killed the snake.
And I was like,
I don't see that thought.
He's such a psycho.
He's not smart.
He just would charge in it and just snap at things like the idea that this thing
didn't bite him.
And he goes,
well,
you know,
if he's feeling bad,
take them back in again.
I bring them home an hour later.
His face has got it growing up,
basketball off the side of it.
I haven't it,
my dog just fucking bring them back in.
But it was expensive.
Two minutes,
which is a real bummer because it's thousands and thousands of dollars for this
antivenom.
And if you're a poor person and they want that money right now,
I know,
man.
I have,
I have pet insurance.
My dog got hit by a car.
$14,000,
sir.
Thank God for pet insurance.
Wow.
I paid like nothing embassy.
It was incredible.
Um,
so pet insurance is unnecessary.
I think my dog got bit by a rattlesnake.
It didn't see the rattlesnake,
but I heard my dog like that and I went,
what the fuck?
And we're walking back.
I'm,
I've,
I've never seen him.
Like,
we're walking back,
my dog's tongue is out and my dog starts weaving and then just kind of falls
over.
Oh,
Jesus.
I picked the dog up.
I bring that dog to the vet.
I thought maybe he got stung by a wasp or something.
I didn't know.
And then I was like,
this,
this sheet.
And I was like,
I think she got bit by a rattlesnake.
And uh,
she was so swollen.
Her head was so,
it led by the time I got there at her head was like,
literally it looked like a giant balloon.
I think my dog got bit by a rattlesnake.
You know what's really crazy ever gave her of antivenom when I think about it.
You know what's really crazy is the venom is actually digesting tissue.
Yeah.
That's what's fucked up like that.
What that venom is for.
Like,
if they bite a snake,
like a snake bites around a rabbit or some shit like that,
it's actually digesting the rabbit so that cause they don't have like a stomach
click we have their,
their whole body is just like one,
just rot track things is rot of it and then they absorb it slowly.
Amputate a lot of science if you don't get to it.
Yeah.
Dirty monsters.
Do you ever see that video that I posted that I got from one of those guys that
I follow on Instagram,
but uh,
they were in the desert and his big fucking huge fat rattlesnake had a rabbit
and was dragging the rabbit away.
This is lifeless rabbit is being dragged away by this thing that's as thick as
my forearm.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
See if you can find it.
Good luck finding it.
Probably four years ago,
three years ago,
four years ago.
Is it?
Found it [inaudible] man,
how do you do that?
Watch this.
So this thing,
look at this.
It's got the rabbit.
Wow.
Yeah.
And they,
they close in on it and it just drags it away.
Wow.
It's creepy.
And if this is a different video,
the one that I had,
um,
it was a bigger snake in it pulls it away way quicker,
but it's just,
it's just a gross little animal.
But then again,
you need those gross salon,
uh,
animals like that's the same lick.
The argument that people say you don't want coyotes in your neighborhood.
Well,
okay.
I kind of see what you're saying,
but the problem is you don't want rats in your neighborhood either.
Stupid.
Yeah.
And Coyote is going to kill the rats.
They do.
Right.
What does this one,
the mom,
rabbit comes in,
fucks up the snake.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah,
Really?
sure.
Yeah.
The mom rabbit recognizes some shit is going down.
Fucks up that snake.
Okay.
Get off my baby.
Look at that.
Yeah.
Rabbits are fucking fierce man.
Man.
In Span,
lots of video where a kid stopped,
uh,
cat,
I think it was like a bobcat.
Small Bobcat,
like in a village was getting attacked by a sim snakes and it was protecting its
babies and the mom just left the babies to die or whatever.
Cause she knew that she couldn't fight it.
The kid just grabbed the snake by the head and walked away and threw it like in
the Bush,
came back and grabbed the baby's and gave them back to the mom.
It was a crazy video,
like eight year old kid,
maybe younger crowd and it was wild.
Grabbed a snake,
grabbed the snake.
It was a eight,
seven,
six 58 foot snake,
six to eight foot,
probably crazy.
Some kids grow up hard,
dude.
No idea what country I was a kid.
I would grab snakes.
If I saw a snake,
I'm going for it.
I was obsessed.
I know I'd grab whatever,
but I didn't live in a place where there were poisoned snakes.
Well,
when I lie,
when it lives in Florida,
I was always worried about running into an alligator.
We'd run into alligators and a snapping turtles.
A lot of snapping turtles,
some snakes.
There are some snakes we'd run into do.
The problem with Florida is,
yeah,
once in a while there's a crime in American crocodile or they even say in the
everglades,
they got couple of miles out there.
Oh yeah,
they do.
A couple of the old Nile crocs assholes who,
uh,
got them as in the 70s and then just let them loose and now they have a viable
population as the sounding board doing the kid,
it almost seems fake because they have cameras everywhere.
I think that's what he does it,
regardless of the fact that it's a pet python.
I would've done that in a heartbeat as a kid.
So he's pulling on it.
Is that a python?
Oh,
they set this up,
right?
That's what I mean.
I as I was pulling it back up and seeing all the cuts and I was like,
okay,
that might not be real.
This is a set.
A set is not real.
This is set up.
Look,
that kid's been grabbing sneaks his whole life.
He grabbed that thing.
I'd expertly,
I'd make that thing a cock holster.
That's what I would do.
A Cock coster cock rings.
I just dumped a bunch of cock rings or a Congo Holster motherfuck into a belt.
Yeah.
It's like growing up like that around snakes and all kinds of evil fucking shit
like that.
Have you been to South Africa?
No.
Cape Town.
I'm scared.
Okay.
Task the most beautiful place I've ever been in my life.
That was,
I saw a wild,
that's a lie,
but thanks for playing.
It is.
No,
it might be the most beautiful place I've ever seen.
Just like,
wait,
it looks,
oh fuck.
It's incredible.
It's so beautiful.
Bring up Cape Town.
It's ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
When I saw it,
I saw one.
For me,
it's ridiculous.
It's not that.
It's just,
it's so beat up.
Bad Looking.
No,
no,
no.
You don't understand like Australia,
we have no idea.
Don't ever bring,
I lost her later.
What about Maui?
It's better.
No,
that's not true.
I've been all over Cape Town.
It's got my number one.
Sure.
It's awesome.
In terms of breathtaking.
Really?
Yeah,
and food.
Any interest in going to Africa and going hunting?
What?
The Africa now four times.
It's a long flight.
What would would it be?
Hunting antelope,
shit like that.
Kudu.
I love Kudo Ivy League guy.
It's delicious,
but at the end of the day I feel you'd get the same in a way.
I feel like you'd get the same cause that,
can I tell you what that would be?
You'd go to a game reserve,
which is probably a cattle,
uh,
an an abandoned cattle range.
Yes.
And they stocked the area with those animals.
And so in a way I think you could get the same exact feeling in Texas.
Yeah.
In Texas,
right.
Texas.
And I'm not kidding.
And in Texas you could go get Texmex.
Correct sir.
Some great food in Africa,
there are a lot of those issues.
Right.
So,
so the,
the trip,
by the time you get there,
you're older,
it's just too fucking,
they're older 16 hour flight,
16 hours.
But then you've got to take a fucking bus and the whole field,
whole thing and something goes wrong every time.
What do you got to doing that photo?
I just flashed up at Cape Town,
just made me think of something I saw yesterday that,
I don't know if you saw it's a so they can create a picture like this.
Oh yeah,
I did see that.
If you draw like a little sketch,
they could turn that into like instantly turned that into a photo.
Realistic.
Hmm.
So I mean you
haven't seen that?
No,
this just came out yesterday.
Today's fucking bananas.
So look at that sketch on the right.
So through the software rendering,
they could do something like that on the left and then they make it on the
right,
but make it with a lake and a mountain.
Like watch this.
Bam.
Damn.
Yeah.
So this is within seconds they can create this.
And what does this software call Jamie?
I don't know that the software from an I saw has made by Nvidia,
which is a veg video card maker and all sorts of other things for [inaudible]
never be able to replace comics.
No,
no,
I don't think they're going to be able to figure out personality.
But I think what they can,
they'll never figure out.
Joey Diaz
take what they can do is make artificial reality.
They're going to be able to make artificial reality.
It's like how long will it take before that artificial reality?
I don't think you can quantify creativity.
I don't think,
I don't know.
I might be wrong though.
I agree that it might be able to figure it out because part of what creativity
is is,
is surprise and almost destruction.
Like when you hear somebody say something you've never heard before or a
different take,
that kind of destroys the old way of thinking.
It's kind of what a lot of creativity and innovation is a form of destruction.
Yes.
And and so destroying ideas.
Yeah,
but like,
like,
like when when you see a great piece of art,
like there's a match to it.
It's an awe.
You're awestruck.
Like the Vatican,
the inside of the Sistine Chapel,
perfect example.
I mean you're,
you're,
you're on that a human being did that for the sake of beauty in itself,
like almost lives of hundreds of years
and generations of artists,
right?
They'd work on the same tapestry or something like three d that is an act of
faith and you're doing it for its own sake.
You're not even doing it because you're making money.
It's like you,
you are doing it because you can and because you want to see what you're capable
of.
Like creating beauty for its own sake is,
but it's original.
It's,
it,
it changes in many ways your perspective.
Like you kind of go,
ew,
the soul.
So Nietzsche and Schopenhauer talks about the idea that there's the will,
right?
So as a human being,
you're stuck in this fucking,
I got to eat,
I've got to fuck,
I got to sleep and I got to breed and I eat and I sleep and I fucked so I can
bring it,
you know,
and I can stay alive and then,
further my gene pool.
And you're stuck in this kind of like will to live.
There's don't,
but there is a risk bite.
And that respite is,
is when you,
when you see a great work of art or you're doing great works of art and somehow
when you see something beautiful,
when you're laughing,
really hard,
equate standard,
when you're seeing all them an amazing movie like American beauty,
the state it puts you in is so incredible because it gets you to forget
momentarily about your own biology,
about your own,
your own needs,
your own watts for what a reason you,
you rest in this state of majesty,
this sort of high relief,
this your higher self and you go,
you go man,
that might be what God's about.
That might be what it's like to be touching something bigger than myself or
bigger than all of this other appetite stuff.
Like I,
it's almost like,
um,
it's almost like something you,
you forget that you forget about death and you forget about your fears and
everything else.
You know,
that those feelings of inspiration that can happen when you're listening to
great music or it can happen when you're making great music.
But that is almost the only time you have,
um,
I guess,
and of course we can talk about flow and you're climbing a mountain with no
ropes or whatever it might be.
I think that puts you in those states of true focus and true flow and um,
that's what we stay alive for.
We stay alive for that.
And when you are not that,
you know,
everything else becomes drudgery.
It almost,
because everything becomes,
and I would even,
I wouldn't even equate like,
oh,
we stay alive also not just for our accomplishments but like when you're with
your friends like we're doing,
if I companion and we're laughing and being silly geese for no other reason,
there is a flow to that.
Oh yeah,
there's a,
you are,
you are removed for temporarily from the world,
from,
from the reality of your own limitations.
And there,
there's something that's so beautiful about that.
I think Nietzsche talked about the idea that you can,
you can actually make your life that your life should be a work of art,
live dangerously and leave a good looking corpse.
Don't,
don't,
don't worry about all the other things.
Just,
just it's worth living at the lead.
She was a mess.
They're all a mess.
That's part of the problem.
And listening to him,
every fucking philosopher,
I've done my own studies on that.
Every philosopher didn't get laid and they lived alone and some of us live with
their mothers and they were all a disaster but they thought deeply they have the
concepts,
they've concepts and oftentimes the not really putting these concepts of
practice in their own life,
which is very strange.
That's right.
Yeah.
That's very true.
Those moments that we have when we're doing the fight companion where we're just
fucking howling and laughing.
Oh that's,
that's why.
And and those,
you can't recreate that.
You know,
one of the things that's interesting about fight companion is a bunch of people
who've tried to recreate it,
they've done their own and they always have been give up.
Cause cause we're really friends,
we're really friends and we really go hard.
That's what I said about getting fucked up.
I mean,
how,
how many shows are there where people are just getting drunk and saying
ridiculous Shit live in front of millions of people now.
And then we'll have a show where there's a,
you a,
you know,
UFC that may,
may get 100,000 pay per view buys and we get 5 million views.
Is that how many is that?
How many we get between the v the in between Youtube and iTunes.
And next time I take my shirt off,
I gotta be at,
I gotta be a little more Jack.
Well,
Lucy don't have psoriasis anymore.
That's true.
But Sha Sha likes people that try to come,
like,
they're like,
well,
you know the fighter and the kid,
I want to start my own podcast.
Well,
how do I go?
We're friends,
we're really friends.
That's why it works.
You can't let just make it like the monkeys fucking organize a fake band.
No fucking way.
We're just,
we're just friends.
No matter.
Right.
And Eddie is legitimately crazy and he's also legitimately a Jujitsu genius,
you know,
innovative fucking,
and he really does think the earth is flat like him.
And I have conversations with,
I'm like,
Eddy,
stop,
stop.
What'd you go flat?
You never go back.
I mean,
what does that mean?
What does that mean?
He's so great.
I don't understand that thinking,
but that's part of the reason why he's fun.
You know?
I was saying,
I was talking about him the other day.
I was there like he bugs me about,
I go,
he's a genuinely good person.
Oh,
he's awesome.
He said Jenny loved that.
I love,
he's been one of my best friends for 20 fucking years.
That's why,
cause he's such a good person.
Yeah,
he's a great guy.
He's a great person and he's like,
he's brilliant when it comes to Jujitsu.
I mean really brilliant.
But like his unique way of thinking is creativity is what allowed him to
formulate that system.
That system of Jujitsu was a lot of very unorthodox and,
and submissions.
It was very,
very,
very clever with his Jujitsu.
Very clever.
So important.
But that,
you know,
you wonder sometimes his brain,
that kind of brain can have it cuts all the way across.
It can have liabilities.
Your strengths are the same as your liabilities?
Well,
he'll have that super obsessed with computer conspiracies,
like legitimately super obsessed,
but it wasn't always,
it's a form entity though.
It's also gives you a tribe and it gives you people,
all of us have that.
Yeah,
well he does that tin foil hat podcast to at Sam Tripoli and then they do
conspiracy,
standup comedy with a go to perform in clubs together.
But it's really selling well.
I mean,
they're doing it great.
Great for Sam too.
Yeah,
that's good to see.
Sam's a great guy.
He was like I was saying earlier,
world versus insanely fortunate in our circle of friends and insanely fortunate
and the camaraderie that we all have to all protect each other and look out for
each other and support each other.
And I noticed that too.
They come,
I feel so lucky that I,
I,
I get to just stand up because the challenge never goes away.
And then I,
I,
I see a lot of actors like Sean Penn,
like Johnny Depp,
like the guys.
I really look up Mickey Rourke and something happens to them along the way.
Brad Pitt,
not so much,
you know,
but the real actors that I really kind of thought were,
there's something goes on like I think had had a real struggle,
then he married a crazy lady.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Married a chicken was ridiculously hot,
but crazy as fuck.
I think they might get,
I dunno,
acting doesn't,
when you,
when you've done a movie,
when you're on set,
you're shooting a page a day and that mundane,
repetitive process,
you're in costume.
You're saying the same fucking lines,
knowing the same scenes over and over again.
Right.
I'm sorry man.
You're there 16 hour days and I don't think that's as satisfying.
No matter who you are,
it becomes a very peculiar skill that it's not like doing a play here.
It's different because standup is standup though you're writing and you have to
perform it.
And it's always changing it.
I agree.
But I also think that you and I were supposed to do stand up like a guy who made
clocks.
That's his passion.
The guy who fixes cars.
Like there's certain people,
like my friend Steve Strope who uh,
built my corvette and you know,
he builds a bunch of muscle cars and shit that fights this loves cars.
He loves the construction of them in the design of them and he loves putting
them together.
And now Daniel Day Lewis and Christian Bale is supposed to be actors.
There's people that are astonished,
do that,
they're really good at,
but then there's other folks that get into it and then become disillusioned
along the way because the process is so weird and also it's so fake.
That's what always drove me crazy.
Like being around all these people that are like not really,
they're talking to you that not really being vulnerable than not really being
present.
They're putting on the little acts,
but also the trap is having a persona.
I think like Johnny Depp got caught up in that persona,
became a pirate scarves in real life.
You can't be that vein.
You have to have friends like me and you.
If I showed up,
I showed up with a lace hanky hanging out in my,
my pocket.
It came all the way down to my knee.
You tackle me hotel.
It's like Jimmy Burke.
When I showed up after mad TV,
I showed up in New York and I decided to start wearing Kangle hats backwards.
They look good on me and I was hot.
I decided I'm going to be a good look and talk cause I saw some active duty and
I and I go there.
[inaudible]
dude,
I'm so fucking proud of you.
I'm at the bar with all the guys.
I'm so proud of you bro.
It's gonna go out,
smoke a Doobie,
celebrate,
raise a glass,
take the hat off right now I'm gonna slap the shit out of you.
Okay.
What about for Doris?
My hand,
he goes,
it's too busy.
It's busy.
But if a Dora that's a that's,
that's the best.
No.
What's the ultimate?
A Straw hat.
Oh,
I'm a member of the press.
Now.
A baret is if you were a fucking Baret,
I'm going to throw in a French braid and throwing you in a flying headlock.
Even if your Broccoli Asthma,
if you have a baret and a cigarette holder,
like,
like hunters Thompson,
I kinda like you if you're a dandy,
if you're a dandy and you have an ear trumpet and a cigarette holder.
Now I like you.
I have a hard time with dudes who wear vests.
Me Too.
I do want,
I do want to dress like that.
Like,
uh,
like a a salsa dancer.
I want to be a Cuban gentlemen at the end of the day.
Like I do kind of want to be,
I want to wear linen suits.
I want to be an older gentleman and I want to smoke fine cigars.
There is the,
or a pipe there is part of me and I want to pontificate and I want to hang out
with Stephen West and I want to talk about philosophy.
I like Watson.
Do you smoke cigars?
Never.
Ever,
ever.
So what's stopping you?
I don't know.
It's a store down the street.
I just thought I've still got some cigarettes.
This is a joint,
bro.
Oh Jesus.
A blunt.
Yeah,
I like that.
it's tobacco on the outside.
Oh really?
Oh,
this is the shit that crashed Tesla stock was down six.
That'll hurt my lungs,
man.
Is it mostly weed?
Oh yeah.
The inside's we'd
get a little,
little head rush from the tobacco.
They need get a little
little,
little life.
I'm such a lightweight life inside the brand because of the marijuana.
No,
we only had some wine.
It be perfect pink for breakouts and fine whiskey and have some fine whiskey.
We don't have any glasses and we'll be all right.
Or it could just drink another glass.
Like gentlemen,
I got to the bottom of mean.
Do we have any more of this?
Yeah,
we have cups.
You have to get out of here.
No.
All right.
I never have to.
Oh,
sorry.
I'm here.
Um,
we have,
let's,
did you have a special drop on?
Oh God,
I'm glad you mentioned that.
Uh,
complicated eight guys get my,
uh,
my number one selling,
one hour and I'll be at,
in Kansas City.
It can't stay in prompt this Friday,
Saturday,
and then I'll be in a walk.
Sit.
Philly's already sold out,
but then I'll be out Calgary on the fourth,
fifth and 6th of April.
This stuff,
single malt scotch and this stuff is made by a boy band.
I like good whiskey.
I don't like this bullshit.
Where does this come from?
I'm not trying to Bang Bang whiskey.
I believe it's the Florida Georgia line's whiskey.
Oh,
okay.
They're not a boy band.
They're a band band.
I thought it was like in sync or some shit at what point in time.
But there's a boy band ever get to a point where they're like,
okay,
we can't call ourselves a boy band anymore.
We're 40 I,
yeah,
we're still rolling.
It's a man.
It's a man band.
They're still back street caught a man bed.
There's euro glass empty there.
No finish across fuckface hold on.
Oh,
you're gonna pour it in there.
I'll put the coffee in there.
Good move.
I can put the whiskey in there.
I'll have them one gallons obviously.
Cause that was Scott.
I believe it's Scott.
Jesus days is much.
What you're doing take is hazy.
Dented whiskey.
Was it the Irish Scotch Scotch?
The Scots Highlands.
So the Irish stolen from the Scotts.
I don't know.
Is that you're a broke my broke.
You know who from Scotland,
who's was on his way?
I'll Holla who?
Um,
Billy Connolly famous.
Yeah,
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
How old is he?
He's,
uh,
I want to say he's in the 70s.
What happened?
Did he just got some terminal illness?
See if he could find it.
76.
Great comedian,
great comedians.
Supposedly.
I'd never met him,
but supposedly a great guy too.
We're all going,
bro.
Yes.
That's the other thing I think about.
I want to make,
I want to,
I don't want to be too attached to him.
Mortality.
I want make,
that's why number watch
I've been doing the areas you don't have to do doing is I do a,
Sam Harris is not dying.
Not Dead,
sir.
Billy Connolly's sins.
Reassuring musical message to fans.
Okay.
So he's still,
he's still going.
He's got some sort of a cancer and Parkinson's.
It says double dose fucking machine breaks down because I've been doing,
I've been reading,
I mean I was doing Sam Harris's a waking up APP,
real guided meditation.
I've been doing it now for three months.
I actually,
I love it cause I read his book,
spirituality without religion and I really liked it.
I've always dabbled.
I've always thought about meditation,
but I without fail have done it now for over three months and it's only 10
minutes a day.
Sometimes I do a little longer,
you know.
But um,
it's,
it's kind of profound.
I never would have seen the value of it,
but it's a,
it took me a while to see.
He helps.
It's very,
he's,
he's a very good guide because he's been doing it for 30 years and he's a very
smart guy obviously.
He's done a lot of those quiet retreats.
Yeah.
So did go Yuval Harari,
the road Sapient's he goes,
I'm three month retreats.
I mean,
when I started seeing guys were that smart do that,
I kind of went,
this is very interesting,
especially from Sam who's always takes flak for being an atheist,
but he's pretty religious for an atheist.
I mean in terms of how he speaks about meditation consciousness,
uh,
mind versus brain.
You didn't use the term spiritual or appreciate that people say that.
I'm not religious,
but I'm spiritual.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I guess he's,
he's very concerned with the health of his mind and he recognizes the power of
meditation.
You know,
I do a bunch of different things that,
um,
helped me keep my mind clear,
like one of them is running or something about running that I never really
understood until I started doing it.
The form of meditation.
Well,
you're,
yeah,
you're in this sort of weird state of mind where you're just trudging and
breathing and that's all you really can concentrate on.
You don't have much room for other things.
Like when you're really struggling like a,
when I'm running up a steep hill and I'm running with a dog,
he's so much faster than me.
He just fucking takes off.
He took,
I have the best dog man.
He turns around and checks to make sure I'm okay.
He's like,
you're all right.
I'm like,
I'm good dude.
I'm good.
I'm right behind you.
And then he takes off and runs again.
He's loves freedom and he's so,
he's such a good dog.
Like I never worry about them meeting people.
He would just be kissing them.
Like the only thing I worry about is like cats,
like mountain lions.
Shit.
I do worry about that because we do run in these really remote areas and um,
when,
when I do that,
when I'm trudging up those hills,
all I'm doing is breathing.
Shh,
shh.
No
pushing my thighs and I'm fucking trying to get to the top of this hill.
And it had some rough,
steep fucking long hill.
You don't think about Jack Shit other than that.
And then when you do come down,
your heart rate drops and you ready to go again.
You know,
like I'll,
I'll do like a long 200 yard hill.
Like,
I'll spread it as much as I can and I get to the top and I have to catch my
breath.
I don't want to kill myself.
But then when you catch your breath,
it's like during the time where your heart rate is dropping,
you start looking at the actual real magnitude of your problems.
Like what are,
what are they really like,
what,
what is mono are our biggest problems is the way we interact with each other.
Right?
If you had to think about all the problems that people have in the world,
obviously there's the big global ones,
global conflict and war,
financial conflict and weird shit that countries do to each other back and
forth.
But it's human beings in conflict with other human beings.
And how much of that can be avoided,
right?
Like isn't it mostly avoidable like with people with one to one,
two reasonable people?
You and I,
you and I is perfect example.
We've run into some people,
we've run into a person and waste and how wars are.
I think so sometimes of course it's good groups,
well not,
and it's also like sometimes it's about resources.
I mean if you,
if you only have access to one water way and your kids may not be able to drink
water,
you can get genocidal right quick.
Of course there are certain things where you kind of go,
well,
we have to fight for our survival,
but again,
people go to war.
The way you organize men,
young men is not,
well,
we hate them.
That doesn't last as much.
What you do is you,
you go,
hey,
it's about love.
It's about defending our country,
our way of life and you,
you create symbols and propaganda and things for them to march behind.
That's always how you motivate large groups.
How you create an ideology in your,
you know,
you're fighting force.
You need that because they tend to fight for something.
You know?
I think at west point it says a nation to finds itself on what is going to fight
for.
Nobody wants one world government.
Right?
That's one of the things that everybody's scared of.
Like one world,
like what?
One group that runs all the countries on the whole planet.
Like that's too crazy,
right?
That's terrifies all of us.
One group having all that fucking power.
Yeah.
Anytime,
anytime.
One group.
That's my fault.
Problem with a big federal government.
Right.
But like isn't,
I mean it seems that they're all ridiculous at this point,
but if there was laws,
laws that we all agreed on,
like you can't just like you say,
if you go to Singapore with weed,
you're going to jail for like the rest of your life.
You know,
like if you're a dealer there.
Yeah.
They'll,
they'll,
they'll fuck you up and it can't be traveling over there with cocaine or
anything crazy like that.
Yeah.
You're in deep shit.
No jury just to judge Lee Kuan Yew talked about that.
He goes,
yeah,
we hang about seven people a year.
Sad,
terrible.
No,
you know,
just judges.
But how many people die from drugs,
from your drug issue in the United States?
How many people,
how many kids are orphaned?
I was like,
Oh shit.
Hey Man,
they have a perspective.
It's a hard ass perspective,
but we've got to realize that,
that that perspective exists still on this earth.
It's really interesting.
We think of all the different cultures.
Like I was thinking of like stoic cultures and cold northern cultures and they
have to get ready for the winter.
A man or you starve Germans and the Swedes and the Nordic folk.
Yeah.
Time becomes a real factor time with your harvest when all that stuff also no
bullshit.
Some fucking insane genes in these people.
Right.
Like that game of Thrones guy,
you know Brock Lesnar's folk are from that world.
Yeah.
Land of the giants.
This is the craziest hardiest stock serve the real,
the real vikings.
Yeah,
and the real survivors like they have to deal with some shit.
In the winter before there was any kind of cars.
I know those people were living up there riding animals when it was,
God knows how fucking cold war those animals and skins and shit,
they would open the door.
She is blowing and giant beards.
One fire in the center of this fucking house and everyone's gathered around the
fire.
It was all about staying warm man and having enough to eat,
and then you got to worry about some other dudes just like you coming into your
town,
fucking you up by you slept,
taking you as a slave.
Oh my God.
Chopping you up in front of your family.
People just chop people up.
That's right.
And that's the mostly what happened forever.
Mostly what happened.
Yeah.
And by the way,
we're going to impregnate your wife and kill your cancer inside them.
Oh yeah.
Everybody got killed.
Everybody got raped.
And that was normal.
That was life.
And people made it through that to some form of security where they started
thinking about rules and laws and how to force them and keep things civil.
Well,
yeah,
I think it just,
I think the fascinating thing is slavery.
Slavery was the order of the day and the leading philosophers and moral thinkers
of our time from Jesus to the Buddha,
to Muhammad,
to Socrates,
and Aristotle to all of them never,
ever really spoke much about slavery,
about owning other human beings,
about selling someone's children.
That just was never really brought up.
And I mean,
it just wasn't,
you just see it.
It's like it was just what was done.
And then,
you know,
really started the abolitionist movement that they were,
they,
I mean the beginnings of the abolition of slavery worldwide,
you know,
did it?
No,
the British and the 18 hundreds really,
and you know,
did it in specifically Evangelical Christians,
the abolition movement was started by what you'd call,
you know,
fanatic,
Christians.
But they were,
they were,
they risked everything and convinced the crown to enforce a ban on slavery in
the high seas.
So if you were a British naval ship,
even if the Ottoman,
if there was a Turkish ship of the Ottoman ship over there and they had slaves,
the British were spent years and great costs at basically hanging slave traders,
freeing slaves,
all that stuff on the high seas.
It,
you know,
so even though they're obviously,
there was a lot of racism that went on the Brits and their navy,
we're the ones that,
uh,
began the abolition of,
of worldwide slavery.
It didn't allow it on the high seas.
Now,
how amazing is that?
Didn't take place until what?
18 1965 sir eight now listen,
well that's when it was a Boston America.
It was that abolished.
The all countries,
Britain abolished slavery I believe were earlier than America.
So we were 1865 or 1816 and another thing to remember is the United States has
been a country with slavery longer than it's been a country without.
So that gives you an idea of a recent,
that is,
okay.
Stop and think about that.
Yeah.
That number.
1865 seems so recent now.
It used to,
when I was a kid,
it felt like it was forever ago.
I know when I was like five years old,
I thought about slavery.
I thought about it as being like eons and eons in the past.
Do you know what book?
I just read it and it's,
it's the,
it is without,
besides the Bible,
a lot of arguably one of the most influential books ever written in the 19th
century.
What uncle?
Tom's cabin.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I realized I hadn't read it.
And,
um,
well,
I mean I think that the,
it's Harriet Beecher Stowe and,
and I think the legend is that Lincoln said,
so you're the little woman that wrote this book that started this great war
because she,
she put this,
she had never actually,
she was from the north,
but she interviewed fugitive slaves and people who,
you know,
he used to be.
And if you read that book,
man,
it was,
it puts such a face on what slavery,
the brutality.
But it was really about in this country or anywhere where you could take a
woman's child,
eight year old and you get some money and it's the story where the slave trade,
it goes well.
Well by the kid,
he's,
he,
I could fetch a good price for him down south and we'll,
we'll take him when his mom ain't there.
I'm going to go have a go do the chores.
And when she comes back,
you know,
otherwise it's all kinds of hemming and hawing.
And they had slave brokers who would come in and go,
look,
you're plantation is in debt.
You got to start selling some of your slaves.
Now,
I'm not going to take those guys,
but that,
that woman she's got,
she's got those two healthy looking boys and the,
and you would sell them and she could do nothing about it.
That was the reality.
And,
and uncle Tom's cabin,
controversial book because of the way they describe my uncle Tom is a simple 10
and a negro.
But I'll tell you what it did,
is she,
she made you realize in technicolor with a human face just exactly how horrible
it was and what happened to the women who would have to see their children's
sold in front of them and they couldn't do anything.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
But,
but uh,
that's on the blah,
blah,
blah.
It was,
it was,
it was for many people.
What galvanized the north to say,
we can't have,
this is crazy.
Cast slavery.
How crazy is it?
That wasn't 200 years ago.
I know.
That wasn't even 200 years ago.
I know,
man.
That's what,
you know,
that joke that I have about the president being like we became a nation in 1776
people lived to be 100 that's three people going now that's real easy thrill.
We,
we are,
since we are infants and something,
we're in the process of this thing where we're figuring out life what's fair,
what's right,
how to run shit,
and we're,
we're doing it based on this idea that someone had already got it dialed in.
Whether it's through the constitution or whether it's through the democratic
system or whether an educational system,
all the different systems that we have that there,
they're perfect and they're in place and they're ready to rock and there've been
rock solid for generation after Gen.
Wait a minute.
How long have you been around?
I know in the,
wait a minute.
Hold on.
Set.
That's it.
Oh Wow.
So what did they do before that?
What they do?
We know if they do the book,
when did they have the ability to print?
Yeah.
Okay.
That was like what,
500 years ago.
What was the fucking,
when was the printing press?
May in the 14 hundreds if I couldn't Berg.
But then I didn't really take hold until the 16th sense.
So imagine having everything you've read,
someone has to write with their fucking hand.
You have no idea if it's correct.
You have no idea if they're telling the truth.
It is writing it.
Yeah.
It's not for years and years and years.
And that's probably the main reason why they probably had to establish higher
schools of learning.
Well the scribes writing this,
hold on.
What are you doing?
Yeah.
The stuff that you're writing,
how do I know it's true?
What's your method?
Yeah,
right.
When they would write down and there are very people that could,
it was usually the priests and there's a book called how the Irish saved
civilization.
And it's about how the scribes,
how the the,
the,
the Irish priests wrote down all the knowledge.
They wrote it down in books and they carried it with them.
So it's like this whole story of how the libraries had to be painstakingly
imitated.
And then the printing press in the 1400 1445 or whatever,
and Gutenberg,
uh,
invent,
he was a watchmaker and invented this thing called the printing press and nobody
really used it.
But then you could,
like,
you could,
people could disseminate ideas.
It was like the Internet,
you have an idea and all of a sudden instead of having one book for,
you know,
50 miles,
you could print out paper and make multiple copies and send them out dining
room.
And then all of a sudden a guy named Martin Luther goes,
if I have the Bible,
what do I need these corrupt priests for?
What do I need to beat pledge allegiance to still see them.
Never Mentor.
Used to make those posters put them up.
Yeah,
the proclamations and in Bitburg Germany,
by the way,
this,
this guy was,
yeah,
but she ever listened to the Dan Carlin series on that.
I didn't.
Oh my God,
it's amazing.
Dan Carlin's.
He explained Lutherism explained the whole movement and how he got away with it
because he had a high public standing so they didn't prosecute him or sue them
or they figured out a way to translate the Bible where other people could read
it.
They couldn't speak Latin.
That's right.
They figured out a phonetic translation for it so that so that now you have,
so if you have the word of God,
what do I need?
The Protestant Catholic divide was about essentially,
wait a minute,
I don't need to place these to this giant institution called the Vatican with
all the money and the costumes.
What if I just have the Bible and I do it?
Jesus said,
because I can read it right here.
All of a sudden now you're a protestant.
That was what everybody was scared about.
I mean,
must have been the most horrific thing about the religious power back then.
Like Rome had armies,
right?
Yeah,
they,
this was,
this was like when Gingiss Khan was roaming the earth and running through Russia
and Asia and Eurasia.
They,
the Rome was like,
they were thinking about going to battle with these people.
The Mongols like the Rome had armies.
Yeah.
The pope had wives.
This was like really in a lot of ways was almost in an ancient way.
Like a similar position to that the United States has now in terms of the whole
world.
Right.
I'm so high now.
Yeah,
of course you are.
I'm sorry,
but what was,
what was that you gave me because I only took one hit.
It's marijuana.
It's a blunt.
Why am I in a tunnel?
It's good.
Good for you.
There's tobacco on the outside of it.
In marijuana.
In the insult your head.
Why is your heads so beautifully shiny?
There's a beauty to use.
I'm going to be honest with you.
I use a sinner.
You do moist dinner.
Well it looks cause I got you.
I got you a little nervous because you have a nice Patina.
It looks like a bespoke shoe.
Oh look,
a nice show.
See how I bring it back.
Bring it back.
Complicated Age,
Scott.
It's out now.
You can buy it everywhere.
Everywhere.
Amazon shit everywhere.
Wherever you get your content,
you get your joke jokes are you get your funding.
There is 100 million comedy specials out right now.
God,
what?
No.
Yeah.
I don't know what the number is,
but I'm going to say it's 100 million.
Still a rare,
it's going to count them all.
Yeah.
It's still a rare fraternity.
Yeah,
it's rev attorney,
but it's interesting how many of us there are today as opposed to the days of
Yore.
You know,
my question is how much material they bill real love.
You know what I'm saying?
Some of them do you know,
is God damn hilarious right now is Sebastian.
Not that it's not always hilarious,
but he's got some new material that he was dealing at the Improv last night.
Oh my God,
dude,
he's so funny.
So funny.
He's hilarious.
He's just got his own groove.
Like we're talking about Theo von earlier,
like he and Theo,
in my mind,
they're,
they,
they're very similar in that they're their styles,
way different.
Their materials way different,
but they have their own thing.
They have 100% their own things to bash and has his own thing.
It's like a music
and you love him.
So you count on him reacting to these things in a certain way.
It's as unique as like,
you know,
Christopher Walken,
it was all his,
you know,
he's in his zone right now.
You know Sebastian is in his zone,
sold out for seat four shows at Madison Square Garden.
Damn,
that's four sold out seats.
This is amazing for four.
That's like 18,000 seats a show.
That's nuts.
Nuts.
Yeah.
It's gotta be some money.
He's a beast is,
I'm sure there's money in it,
but the point is like he's in that sweet spot of his career.
Yeah.
You know,
that's in a way why I still have faith in the American system because he was a
waiter for nine years.
Yeah.
He was just a smart,
easy going dude who's easy to love Italian.
Yeah.
It's got a lot of that are so fun to watch on state.
I don't want to say what he's talking about and I don't want to ruin any of it
cause you know his stuff hasn't even,
it's on paper.
I would never do it justice.
You have to see him in front of you.
He's funny man.
The same thing I say about Theo.
Theo is in this rare place right now.
You know,
like he's on stage and he's like,
you just start smiling when you see him.
He's his hypnosis game is on point.
Oh it was phenomenal.
I told him today on the podcast he did veteran kid.
I was like,
you're an original man.
He's not beating yourself up for himself up every comic.
Does Brian know every comic does.
I just stopped doing it at 50 to be with this Sam Harris App.
Nah,
I just decided I got tired of 'em.
I've realized I've been doing my best and I got myself here.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
well come on,
there's like a two thing going on,
right?
There's two things simultaneously going on.
There's one that you know you want to do your best and so you look at everything
you do and you go,
I think I could've done that better.
God Damn it.
Why did I do it like this?
Like fuck,
what is that about?
Like what's this about?
Why did I do it like that?
Why not ha rework that,
redo this.
But then there's the other part that has to be like,
look,
why are you doing this?
Like you're doing this because you enjoy it.
Do you enjoy it?
Okay,
you're going to feel gross about anything that doesn't work out well.
Everything that you do that doesn't work out well,
just don't be a bitch about it.
Just get over it.
There's a certain self indulgence involved in dwelling on your mistakes that it
becomes almost like a self pity thing.
You got to there.
There's
a strength in a discipline in learning how to go.
Okay,
are fucked up.
Did you,
did you ever read Martha Graham's letter,
the great,
the mother of modern dance?
She wrote a letter to Agnes.
What do you think when you asked me that question?
Timely and mother of modern dance.
It's timely though,
I'm sure like a,
but it's still funny.
I know because I'm,
I'm asking you about fucking,
how do you know about this?
What is this woman's name again?
I'll show you.
Her name is Martha Graham.
She's the great,
I'm going to just,
it's like a really short letter,
but she wrote this,
she was a great choreographer.
She created modern dance.
She was basically like,
it's not just,
uh,
there's not just ballet.
Let's,
how about just moving naturally and doing crazy shit.
Bring up Martha Graham.
She's,
you had 80.
She was dancing,
but she was that.
She's a giant.
She's an innovator.
They'd be,
when you think of dance,
she'd might be the most famous,
one of the most famous names ever in dance.
Okay.
Whatever.
But she wrote this letter and I think you'll appreciate this.
It's really short.
There's a vitality,
a life force,
a quickening that is translated through you into action.
And because there is only one of you in all time,
this expression is unique.
If you block it,
it will never exist through any other medium.
And be lost.
The world will not have it and it has B and it is not your business to determine
how good it is now,
how valuable it is now,
how it compares to other expressions.
It's your business to keep it yours clearly and directly and keep the channel
open.
You don't even have to believe in yourself and your work.
You have to keep open and aware of directly of the urges that motivate you.
Keep the channel open.
No artist is pleased.
There was no satisfaction,
whatever.
At any time there was only a queer divine dissatisfaction,
a blessed unrest that keeps us marching and makes us more alive than the others.
To him.
That's beast shit.
How about that?
That's on the money ain't then as the old woman,
that's her.
That's her.
She was doing this.
Nobody understood.
What will you send me that?
Yes,
cause I'm so high,
I'm not going to remember it.
So mom came here are really into what she's doing here,
but appreciate her words.
It's like I feel like you shouldn't have showed me this video.
Now,
this wasn't a time when they were only doing it,
like she was doing the craziest shit.
This is how a dance,
if I really hurt my back,
isn't like 1943 if I'm not mistaken,
when through the video people were probably as a 1943 people were probably
struggling then for freedom from the orthodoxy struggling to express themselves
in different ways.
You know,
that's one of the more interesting things about standup is that it's indicative
or it's um,
it's a representative of the time in which it's performed in,
like they were a little windows in time to how people behaved and thought,
and there was some shit that people did
just a 10,
15,
20 years ago that you just can't do now.
Right.
It's like,
it's not,
it's not an,
it's not possible.
It's not,
it's not in the public's a menu list anymore.
Right.
You know,
but back then it was normal.
It's like you,
you can and some stuff just isn't funny anymore.
It's weird.
Like some of the Lenny Bruce stuff,
man,
he was for the time,
he was groundbreaking.
Right.
He just like,
nobody had seen anything like this before.
A guy who was talking straight and true about real social issues and making them
funny on stage and he says,
you know,
handsome looking Jewish fellow with beautiful hair.
And he just had a look.
Just disturbing.
It's comedy.
Shook people up.
Yeah.
But it was,
there was no way that you and I can put ourselves back into the minds of people
that lived in the 1950s when Lenny Bruce was doing this.
There's no way we could put ourselves there.
Right.
We,
we are tainted forever by technology and innovation and the way that it's the
way that interaction I think is the big one right there.
As soon as people started being able to exchange information with each other,
I know,
you know,
whether it's through television and then through,
radio and television and television shows and then Internet and the more they
express themselves,
the more they've sort of figured out patterns of behavior that are acceptable.
Yeah.
But I wonder at times whether or not,
I think standup has,
is having a renaissance but like music and things.
I don't think we're living in a time of genius.
Are We?
Or do I not know enough about some great shit that's being made?
There's just so much that's being made,
right.
Black keys are always putting out great shit.
Gary Clark Jr has an amazing new album.
It's amazing.
I love him.
It's so good.
He's uh,
he's got such a signature guitar sound man.
His fucking guitar sound is like,
I love that style of,
you know,
he's got,
he did a,
um,
uh,
him and honey honey did a show together one night in downtown La Tam and a
recorded some event and put it up on my Instagram and they were doing,
I saw my brothers midnight rider.
Yeah.
See if he could find that.
It was a phenomenal,
crazy man.
She was reading the lyrics off her phone.
I,
she didn't even know the lyrics to the song.
She had to go and get it and she was singing in real time while she's ringing.
Yeah,
I saw that.
I know why she's reading rather.
And so he's doing midnight rider,
but he's doing it Gary Clark Jr style and it's fucking amazing.
One of the cools things about here it is.
Yeah.
You see that's like,
that's his style.
You know what I'm saying?
Jerry Clark.
Oh look at that.
Woo.
He's a killer.
He ever see Stevie Ray Vaughn to new trial.
There's a video.
Never saw him live,
but I almost got to drive them live.
I drove Jeff back when I was,
uh,
when I was a limo driver almost got to drive Stevie Ray Vaughan.
I was thinking I was that he gets to drive Steve.
Very wow.
But he won't take limos.
He would only take cabs to wanted to talk to the cab driver.
Yup.
Man.
The way he treats people.
Well he does with a guitar.
It's just,
he was performing with Jeff Beck and all of his people were in the limos man and
he went into fucking cab to him.
Dan,
he was legit as fuck special man.
It was crazy to me.
Was that Gary Clark Jr he,
Gary Clark Jr that song while still having it be clearly that song.
So cool.
But it was like damn ain't know.
It was so cool,
man.
Due to be there live.
And it was like 12 o'clock at night on Tuesday in downtown La.
There was only maybe a hundred people in the room and Suzanne,
Suzanne Santo from honey.
Honey.
She's so talented,
man.
She looks at the fact that she could read that your voice is insane.
She's reading that off of her phone and singing it so crazy.
Yeah,
but Stevie Ray Vaughan,
we can't put any of this music up.
Hope.
Don't Yank us off the phone.
If I,
if I gave you a,
if I told you that you would have,
if you would,
could trade a deep knowledge and practice of music over your knowledge of
martial arts,
would you take it right now?
Fuck no,
no,
no.
It really,
why would I do that?
You would rather be a better,
a great fighter than an amazing guitar.
Yes.
Yeah.
I don't know how I feel.
I love the arts.
I don't have to make it.
No,
but I can't play at all.
And I'll listen to Gary all day.
I'll listen to this podcast.
You're going to Joe Rogan experience because of my obsession with Jimi Hendrix.
Right?
This is why I did.
I mean,
it's why I need,
I stole it from Jimmy Hendrix.
Right.
I love music,
but I don't have any talent.
No,
I got none.
I'm not no desire,
nothing.
You don't have to fucking make movies,
man.
You don't have to be a painter.
You know?
Tailored boss made this.
Mitzi look at that watch over us in the studio.
I don't want to,
I don't.
I don't have to paint.
No.
Do you get to paint?
I agree.
Do you do,
who do you find hope?
I'm not giving up martial arts for nub.
Nothing.
No.
No Way.
It helps me so much.
It's so,
it's so important for me to do too.
Just to have the ability to get out a hundred percent of aggression and be able
to hit a bag and just get into a flow,
smoke a joint,
and then hit a bag.
You never do that.
I don't.
I'm so high right now.
Last thing I'd want to do is punch somebody.
You might be interested in day two of the 50th anniversary of Woodstock.
Did you hear that they're doing it of all?
No.
What are they doing?
Well,
the lineup just got announced in day two has got Gary Clark Surgical and the
black keys.
Holy Shit.
And,
and David Crosby and chance the rapper and the grateful dead John Mayer.
Who knows?
Wow.
Hmm.
That's a fucking line up,
right?
Their sons Sturgill Simpson and the black keys.
That's two of my top 10.
It's so much music.
What's amazing about music man,
is that they're,
they're still making it.
It's like everyone's still making music.
So it's not like there's,
the database just gets bigger.
It's not like stuff goes away.
Right.
You bring back old Donna summer shit.
You know,
like dude,
I have,
um,
what does that,
uh,
sitting yet,
Mahalo down,
pay bad,
bad man songs that I think it's nowhere to run.
I don't think you're right.
Um,
I got some playlists here thinking this,
but okay.
Allman brothers or James Brown,
like you'd go,
you'd go back in time when you listened to that,
you listened to James Brown song.
It's not just that you're listening to the James Brown,
you're listening to a time capsule from 1963 or whatever it was.
He so astonishing.
James Brown,
he was amazing.
Oh,
like that I,
when I hear Zeplin and I hear Jan's man,
I never get,
I never lose my shock at how good they were,
how unique they were.
Yeah,
know Zeppelin was incredible.
There's the only thing that taints zipline is this.
I know allegations of plagiarism,
which seemed to be totally true.
I know,
I've heard the songs.
You can do that side by side where you're like,
Tam,
you stole those rifts.
Yeah,
that's rough.
It's unfortunate because the end result is fucking incredible.
Like it's still so great that the immigrant song,
one of the best workout songs of all time.
I know
so crazy come from the land of the ice and snow with a midnight sun in the
hotsprings blow.
How much credit do they,
I mean did it,
should they have at the,
I'm not trying to disparage it at all,
but like they should get a lot of credit for how good they were still.
They were still the greatest.
They were definitive there.
The definitive heavy metal.
They're so good.
Bandit Ball.
There's no doubt that they're so good.
See the thing,
is it every song?
I don't know.
You know,
I don't know how every band does it.
Every song was probably constructed differently.
Putting in a lot of cases,
there's a lot of people contributing to the song.
You know,
the drummer has an idea and the singer has an idea and the guitar player has
these rifts he's trying out and they're trying to figure out the best way to do
the song.
It's a collaborative effort.
It's no doubt that the collaboration was fucking phenomenal.
The question is,
was it consensual?
Like how many of these people were collaborating and didn't know it.
So that's what happens if you're plagiarizing it seems like it's okay and you
know,
maybe they just thought that band's going to go away.
No one's going to care about them anymore cause we're OLED motherfucking Zeplin.
That's possible too.
Because before the Internet,
that kind of would have been the case,
you know,
no one but now we recognize still are taking sign it,
it doesn't belong to you.
You definitely are.
So in my opinion,
you have to buy that from the person.
Yes.
Give them credit.
Yes,
but there's no way you can discount the fact that they were motherfuckers when
they were on top.
When Robert Plant would stand on that fucking stage with his shirt open.
I mean he's the,
what's one of the weirdest things,
like what they think about that change in history,
right?
Go from 1950 to 1969 go 19 years and you see,
you go from people that looked like Hank Williams,
Sr two,
a Guy Robert Plant who apparently was wearing the blouses or dresses or tee
shirts that the girl he had the night before at Warren.
Do you know that that's what you'd wear on stage?
That's correct,
sir.
That's what I hear.
So probably fucked his way.
His shirts,
he always worked girl shirts that were too small for him.
When you go to OEC is hog in his pants.
He always had his hog pressed to the side.
Yeah.
The,
the,
every,
every heavy metal band in the 80s poison,
you name it.
Uh,
whatever.
Motley crew,
they all had a blonde lead singer,
but that was cause their hero is Mr Robert Plant?
No,
he's a beast.
He's wearing a girl's shirt.
Oh my God.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
that's amazing.
That's sure.
It barely fits him.
Damn right.
All of so many of those pictures where he was,
what a crazy life.
That guy let look at it.
I don't,
you know,
I don't think any one of us will ever be able to understand.
Even even if you became like the new led Zepplin,
you'll never understand what it's like to be led Zepplin in the 70s in the 70s
what like imagine if you today became the new gigantic auto fucking
multi-country rock.
Doesn't matter too many people watching you.
Well,
it's not just that too many people watching you and there's a lot of you.
You got to think back when Robert Plant was Robert Plant where the royalty,
you were literally like a king.
Yeah.
You had the who you had rolling stones had helped him.
John,
yet people yet people but maybe have 30 yeah,
you might have 30 yeah,
30 big name artists.
Maybe.
Maybe,
maybe,
but it's true.
Maybe a hundred let's get crazy a hundred you got pink Floyd.
You got the WHO.
When you think about the Beatles,
obviously CDC.
Yeah.
You got all sorts of shit.
You've got a lot,
a lot going on back then.
You know,
of course you have Hendrix,
Joplin,
Janis Joplin,
the doors.
Yeah,
man,
you got a lot of shit.
And then you've got the weird ones,
the mamas and the Papas.
Amazing band.
It wasn't just some weird shit that went on with that family.
Yeah.
But also heroin and cocaine kind of killed all that whole,
that whole music scene.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that.
That's the problem.
It's sort of starts it up and then it poisons it.
Well,
psychedelics and we'd probably good for your music.
When you get into cocaine and heroin,
your music is dying.
Don't panic.
You don't get it that it's bad for you.
But I think it's,
there's,
it can't be a coincidence that so many people that love heroin made amazing
music beforehand though.
So,
so a lot of forehand.
Yeah.
Look at Lou Reed.
Any of them who got into heroin,
their music stopped.
Lou Reed was always,
even Hendrix and Jim Morrison,
I mean a lot of the songs that Hendricks was riding me,
he died at 27.
So that was a relatively new,
his musical development I think was done less with,
you know,
maybe,
uh,
psychedelics,
but I don't think heroin played a factor until later on in his life.
So,
um,
it's hard to say,
you know,
no,
I know he was arrested in Toronto with heroin.
I don't know the whole history of is I don't buy that time.
He's so famous.
He had already written those songs that got them there.
You know,
maybe,
I mean,
I don't know when he started using heroin or why,
you know,
I don't think heroin makes you more,
um,
uh,
more artistic or more successful at all.
But I think what happens is you have very talented people that have a substance
abuse problem.
You know,
that's what Steven killed king said.
He said,
I,
I'm a great writer,
but I don't remember writing Cujo yeah,
my alcohol didn't make me a better writer.
I'm a really imaginative,
talented writer who happens to have a substance abuse problem.
And ask a bit of it.
Yes and no.
Yes and no because yes,
he is unbelievably talented.
Yes.
He's an amazing writer is one of my personal favorites.
I mean I probably read more Stephen King books in any other fiction author,
but the stuff that he wrote when he was doing drugs was hard core shit.
He wrote the shining and Cusco and the Tommy desires,
one of the best.
He wrote all sorts of wicked books,
men where there's just evil and tensions and ruthless actions and shocking
scenes.
And the fact it was a coincidence he was doing coke.
It's just a coincidence he was drunk.
No,
I think I don't leave.
I wrote the books though.
I think what he did,
and no one's saying that,
look,
vitamin C doesn't make a person,
right.
It's these are,
these are tools to squeeze the most out of your imagination while suppressing
any sort of,
uh,
any sort of societal handcuffs he might've put on yourself because of the
horrific notions.
Like he said,
he would say things in his book where you would go,
whoa.
Like you would have to take a step back.
Like,
where the fuck what?
What kind of fucking person thinks this up?
What kind of person?
I'll tell you what kind of person,
a guy who's drunk as fuck doing coke,
who's also a great writer.
It's not that it is not capable of writing that stuff and digging into is,
I'm not saying that I think you probably could have achieved the exact same
results on the Nache.
Yeah,
because he,
Steven motherfuck.
Okay.
Might've his mind from all over are also positive possible rather that that
stuff is rocket fuel.
It's rocket fuel for your,
your,
your physical energy,
your anger,
your moods,
your inhibitions dissolve and it might open up the pathway.
Did that for picking door of demon rape that you didn't want to get to hear him?
I cannot be.
Comes to like it gives you a scene in a Stephen King book gives you courage.
Oh,
what the hell is that?
Cemeteries came out,
what is it that just brought up maybe remade it today or last week or something
and it goes out week or two.
Yeah.
Is it a comedy?
Definitely not.
I heard it.
I heard it's really good.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh,
John Lithgow is,
I've got to go kids.
Okay.
It's always good.
You gotta go.
I gotta go close it down Brian,
and thanks fine.
Thank you.
How to move for,
thank you for having the number one comedy special on the planet Earth.
Something on the item.
It's told me that I think I saw it.
All right,
good.
So at myself.
Um,
complicated apes.
Yeah.
Come see me this weekend.
Where are you at?
Kansas City improv Saturday.
That's a great club.
Yeah.
I hope I'm not still high.
I don't know what your there be you guys.
Brian,
Callan.
Complicated Apes.
Cause that's what we are indeed.
All right sir.
Thank you very much.
Love you.
Always good to hang with you.
We should do this more often.
We always say that.
Oh,
it's a blast doing it like every couple of months now.
Right?
Jamie?
When was the last time?
Just Brian.
Brian?
How much?
I don't know.
Six months.
Two years.
My beard,
Dude.
Time's flying too quickly now.
Let's do it every few months.
Thank [inaudible].
Thank you.
I'm down please.
Bye Bye Buddy.